So, moin Leute, zingloriere, wie auch immer, die ausgesprochen wird, danke für den Sub.
Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, ich wusste gar nicht, dass salziger Hoden, irgendwie top,
was ist das denn hier überhaupt oben?
Was ist das überhaupt, keine Ahnung, Topgifter ist, ich weiß nicht mal, was die Anzeige überhaupt
bedeutet, Top, Top, Subgifter, hat er sich umbenannt an den Namen, kann ich mich jetzt
gar nicht erinnern, der hätte ich mir doch gemerkt, ach Weekly Topgifters, ah Weekly
Topgifters, Anygifters, wie macht man das jetzt wieder weg?
So, ich bin müde, obwohl ich eigentlich sogar ein bisschen später dran bin als letzte
Woche, ok, quasi dritter Tag heute.
Ich bin immer noch echt enttäuscht von dem Game, es hat auch kaum Inhalt, es wird überall
gesagt, so nach dem Motto, was in dem Game alles drinne steckt, Hazard Zone, Portal und
das normal, aber das Spiel hat kaum Inhalt, zumindest kaum Inhalt darauf, wo es ankommt,
man kann ja nicht Portal immer als Ausrede für alles verwenden, so nach dem Motto, ja,
aber Portal, das Spiel muss in der Kerndisziplin liefern und in der Kerndisziplin, also sprich
All-Out-Warfare, hat's nix, es hat zwei Spielmodi, Breakthrough spielt sich auf der Hälfte
der Maps einfach nur grottenschlecht, auf manchen sogar wirklich gut, muss man sagen,
Conquest ist einfach riesengroß und du bist die ganze Zeit nur am rumrennen, Hovercraft
sind OP, ja fuck, ich hab gestern irgendwie ein 45-Kill-Hovercraft-Gameplay, in dem ich
einfach nur im Kreis gefahren bin und immer auf den Gunner-Sitz gewechselt hab, ja, Portal
ist broken as fuck, versucht man Bad Company 2 zu spielen, die Drohne ist unzerstörbar,
also im Prinzip, leider, leider, bisschen wenig für das Geld, ja, wir lassen uns heute
nicht, wir lassen uns nicht G-Baiten von Level Cap, weil Level Cap hat nix zum G-Baiten,
normalerweise gucken wir uns ja mal ein Level Cap Video an, aber gibt es nicht, der war
zu sehr beschäftigt mit Battlefield Stream diese letzten zwei Tage, aber ich sehe hier
dran, dass der auch den EA Sellout macht, nämlich das hier, er sieht garantiert EA,
wobei, da bin ich mit, das ist definitiv EA Sellout, das Video, Hazard Zone, definitiv,
bin ich mir sicher, lass mal gucken, ha, ich wusste es, lass mal gucken, was ist das, wir
haben ein großes Problem, hey Battlefield, da hab ich ein bisschen reingeguckt, ja, aber
ich finde, also, es gibt noch kein Video, also ich hab noch kein Video gesehen, der wirklich
treffend das zusammengefasst hat oder das gesagt hat, was ich, was ich so insgeheim
über das Spiel denke, es ist einfach komplett uninspiriert, so ein Schatten von Battlefield
im Endeffekt, es hat Elemente von Battlefield, aber vieles von dem, was Battlefield ausgemacht
hat, ist einfach nicht da, wie gesagt, fängt mit Serverbrowser und Scoreboard an, fängt
mit Klassen und Squads, gehts weiter, wobei ich ja immer noch die Specialist an sich gar
nicht mal so für eine blöde Idee halte, also, es ist einfach so ein, ein uninspiriertes
Machwerk, ja Soundtrack hat es auch nicht wirklich, das hatten wir gestern aber, das hatten wir
gestern auch in einem normalen Breakthrough Match, dass die Leute sich nicht wiederbeleben
können und auch nicht respawn sind, ja, das ist ja der Trend aktuell, dass man die Sachen
quasi immer weiter weichspült, ich fand Battlefield und man muss es ja auch bei Battlefield 5 und
1 irgendwie noch zugute halten, klar, da haben sie auch schon ein paar Sachen entfernt,
Server konnte man nicht mehr richtig machen, aber das war noch quasi ein, also ein Multiplayer
PvP Game, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal PvP Game, durch und durch, das Battlefield war
ja nie overcompetitive oder so, also so übertrieben competitive, das war noch nie irgendwie jetzt
irgendwie CS-mäßig oder so, das war immer quasi schon relativ easy zum Einstieg und
jeder konnte das irgendwie spielen, es konnte auch jeder irgendwie seinen Spaß haben, sei
es mit Fahrzeugen, wo manche richtig Spaß dran hatten, oder Battlefield 4 als Commander
oder halt eben Infanterie, manche haben sich drauf spezialisiert, wir machen jetzt Infanterie,
Sturmsoldat, Bastion, manche haben gesagt, wir machen gar nichts, wir wiederbeleben bloß
die ganze Zeit, das sind einfach so Dinge, die fehlen mir komplett, das ist irgendwie
kein, das ganze Ding fühlt sich an, wie als hat jemand gesagt, wir wollen eigentlich so
eine Art Escape from Tarkov machen mit Hazard Zone oder Hunt Showdown, je nachdem, vielleicht
wollten sie springen auf Bel Royal machen, dachten sie, sie wollten nicht in die Selbstkonkurrenz
machen, keine Ahnung, und dann haben sie festgestellt, das trägt nicht so ganz und haben noch einen
Battlefield drumherum gebaut, so fühlt sich das an, die Bugs, da will ich gar nicht so
sehr drauf rumreiten, dass du manchmal Leute im Team hast, die als Gegner erscheinen bzw.
nicht als eigene Teammates angezeigt werden und du reinbutterst ohne Ende und nichts passiert,
sieht man ja hier, wenn ich weiß wie das ausschaut, guckt euch das mal an, das ist übrigens befreundetes
Teammate, das wird bloß nicht angezeigt als befreundetes Teammate, das sieht halt aus
wie ein Gegner, das ist halt einfach kaputt, aber da sage ich gar nichts mal großartig
dagegen, das sind so Dinge, das kriegen die bestimmt, wenn sie wollen in den Griff, aber
das Spiel hat, um es mal zu sagen, das hat sehr wenig Tiefgang und Substanz fehlen einfach,
das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut und ja, das Spiel ist jetzt vielleicht, naja doch,
das ist im Prinzip, also man könnte sagen vom Verbackungsgrad her, weil irgendjemand
was zu Battlefield 4 gefragt hat, ja hier, da, es ist vom Verbackungsgrad her, vielleicht
ist das überhaupt ein Wort, Verbackungsgrad, also vom Fehlergrad her, ist das ungefähr
vergleichbar mit Battlefield 4, es hat ähnliche Klitsches und sowas, aber das Problem ist,
was Battlefield 2042 nicht hat, ist irgendwie so Tiefgang und Vielfalt, guck mal, Battlefield
4 hatte, was weiß ich, wie viele Spielmodi standardmäßig drinnen, man kann sich jetzt
drüber streiten, ob da alles gut war, sicherlich nicht, ja, ab Battlefield 4 ging es mit Rush
bergab, aber das Spielmodi in Battlefield 4, du hattest massig Customization, was Waffen,
Attachments und vor allem Fahrzeuge anging, also du konntest ja in Battlefield 4, du konntest
ja Fahrzeuge, du hattest ja gefühlt, das war ein eigenes Game, die das gemacht haben,
du hattest zwar die gleichen Maps in allen Modi, allerdings immerhin noch gut durchdacht,
aber du hast in Battlefield 2042 nicht mal TDM, und nein, Portal ist keine Ausrede für
alles, dazu kommt, dass sich die Fahrzeuge in Battlefield 2042, ich weiß, das soll mehr
simulationsmäßig sein, aber das fühlt sich einfach beschissen an, das muss ich jetzt
eigentlich, also die Fahrzeugphysik, sei es jetzt der Jeep oder Hovercraft, das fühlt
sich einfach beschissen an, meiner Ansicht nach, also Battlefield 4 hatte halt noch so
den goldenen Kern irgendwie zur Release, obwohl es verbackt als Fuck war, aber diesen Kern
sehe ich bei 2042 nicht, so, das ist das, was ich mir dazu denke, ah, das willst du
machen, ne, nix, kannst du nix machen, ich bin echt enttäuscht von dem Game, der Hovercraft
kann auch über Gebäude fliegen, weiß ich, ob es dazu Videos gibt, müsst ihr euch mal
angucken, das Hovercraft Fly, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, man sieht es irgendwie, achso, da fliegt
ein Sturm rein, also du kannst mit dem Hovercraft auch von Gebäude zu Gebäude springen und
sowas, also das Hovercraft ist brutal OP, aber da sage ich gar nichts dagegen, das kann
man alles noch patchen, das ist okay, aber das Game hat halt ganz fundamental nichts
zu bieten, hast du das mit den FBI Mails mitbekommen, ne, was war denn da, hab ich nicht
mitbekommen, tja, Game ist halt dead, leider, ja, mal gucken, wie es zu Weihnachten aussieht,
ja, also ich warte so mit meinem endgültigen Fazit noch ab, bis es nächste Woche rauskommt
und der Day One Patch, oder wie auch immer man das da nennt, Day Seven Day Patch raus
ist, ne, ich glaube, wir kriegen den Sauber nicht voll, die Leute müssten sich ja Venice
installieren dafür, tja, doch das Scoreboard ist doof, weil zum
Beispiel, du siehst ja überhaupt nicht, was die anderen machen, also du guckst auf deine
Tickets, du guckst auf deine Tickets, das hast du total oft, du siehst, okay, wir sind
400 Tickets down und du fragst dich, warum, so nach dem Motto, du hältst irgendwie 80%
der Objectives, bist trotzdem oder 70% der Objectives und bist irgendwie trotzdem 500
Tickets down am verlieren, denkst dir, warum und du siehst es einfach nicht, du kannst
es nicht einschätzen, warum, ohne Scoreboard, weißt es nicht, bei Battlefield 3,4 und den
anderen ist es relativ easy, du machst das Scoreboard auf und siehst entweder, ah, okay,
das Gegnerteam hat irgendwie die ultra krassen Helidudes mit 500 Kills oder du hast selbst
welche, zwei Drittel von dir im Team haben halt irgendwie 0,45 oder so, klar, ja und
wenn du das nicht siehst, weißt du, okay, der aktuelle Stand der Flaggen spiegelt halt
nicht das komplette Game wieder, sagst du, okay, wir haben jetzt vielleicht zwei Drittel
der Objectives, aber wir haben ja anscheinend trotzdem ganz gut gekillt, sind trotzdem down,
das heißt, wir waren wohl das restliche Game, die Flaggen und also du brauchst das Scoreboard,
um überhaupt rauslesen zu können, warum das Game jetzt so ist, wie es ist, ja, nee, auf
jeden Fall jetzt noch nicht, tja, das kommt auch noch dabei, das kommt ja auch noch dazu,
also ich sag euch mal so, es fühlt sich nicht gut an einen Bot zu killen in einem Multiplayer
PvP Spiel, aber wisst ihr was sich noch beschissener anfühlt, wenn ein Bot killt, was durchaus
mal vorkommt, weil die dann der Meinung sind, ah, wir machen jetzt Instant Headshot oder
so, normalerweise sind Bots easy in dem Game, die bewegen sich auch total bescheuert, aber
manchmal, wenn der Bot direkt vor dir steht und der Meinung ist, der furzt dir jetzt im
Kopf mit einem Burst, dann bist du trotzdem down.
Es ist aktuell halt noch nicht so viel, weil nur Pre-Ordered sind, also man sieht schon,
ich hatte gestern einige Bots, es ist ja aktuell nur Pre-Order oder diese Gold-Edition-Geschichte
und sowas, ich denke mal ab nächster Woche wird man noch weniger Bots sehen, aber trotzdem
allein schon, dass Bots drin sind, ist einfach nur Pains-Champ.
Du kannst Breakthrough spielen, also Breakthrough ist schon ähnlich zu Rush, der Unterschied
ist nur, dass auf diesen Maps, also Breakthrough der Unterschied von Breakthrough zu Rush ist,
Rush legst du in den Elmkomb, dann ist es weg, in Breakthrough nimmst du einen Punkt ein
und du musst alle Punkte einnehmen, dass es weitergeht, also sprich, wenn du zu viele
Leute rüberschickst zur anderen Flagge wird die zurückgecaptured und sowas, das Problem
ist, dass du hast zum Beispiel Maps wie Discarded, das ist das mit dem Schiff, mit diesem Container-Fragschiff,
da ist die ersten zwei Flaggen, Breakthrough, legit ein flaches Feld, mit auf der linken
Seite zwei Container und eine Flagge und auf der rechten Seite zwei Container mit einer
Flagge.
Das ist ein komplett flaches Feld mit irgendwie 10 Kilometern dazwischen oder so, du kannst
auch nicht einfach mal sagen, ah, das ist halt was, was ich halt auch dumm finde, du
bist nicht an A und sagst, oh Mist, Attack auf A1, ich laufe schnell rüber, du läufst
nicht schnell rüber, du brauchst drei Minuten bis du da drüben bist, ewig, na gut, du kannst
den Hovercraft droppen, wenn du gerade droppen kannst und dann OP im Kreis fahren, alles
special, was ist denn heute los, ey, Sack, ai ai ai, und es droppelt, trotz doppelt Corona
geimpft, vielleicht brauche ich auch die Booster-Impfung, kriege ich überhaupt eine mit 37 oder kriegt
das, kriegt man das nur 60 plus, wie erkennt man Bots, das siehst du am Namen, die haben
also die haben einmal ai hinterm Name und die heißen auch so militärmäßig, so was
weiß ich, Sergeant Umut oder so und dann weißt du, wenn die so heißen, dann sind das Bots
oder es steht halt auch ai drinnen, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, und wenn du dich übrigens, wenn
du in das Spiel reingehst und ein gutes Squad hast und dir denkst, cool, mit den Jungs
spielen wir jetzt eine Runde, nope, nach jeder Runde disbandet das Squad automatisch, du
müsstest also quasi ultra schnell die Leute adden und selbst dann wird das Spiel neu
zusammengestellt, nächste Runde, es ist gar nicht so, dass du gegen die gleichen Leute
spielst, das ist richtig, richtig bescheuert gemacht und ich sag euch, da läuft im Hintergrund
erst sowas wie Skill-Base-Matchmaking, ich sag es euch, wie es ist, das ist zwar kein
Skill-Base-Matchmaking-Cod-Style, aber es ist definitiv spürbar oder die ganzen Pre-Order-Leute
sind einfach nur mega auf Zack alle, achja, die Time-To-Kill ist auch ziemlich hoch,
und ich hab so große Schwierigkeiten wie noch nie zuvor in einem Game, einfach auf
Target zu bleiben, aber mag auch an mir liegen, ne, ist wieder alles weg, ich schwalte nach
einer Runde, Pepo, Pupu und dann geht es wieder, die 6 Monate sind bei mir noch der
2.
Impfung noch nicht rum, bin in der ersten Zeit, was weiß ich, 2, 3, 3 Monate, ich hab
es doch auf Twitter geschrieben, Moment, ich hab geschrieben, mir wächst was aus dem Arm,
mir wächst was aus dem Arm, hab ich geschrieben, warum ist das da nicht, warum findet man das
nicht, über Twitter, da weiß ich, wann ich geimpft wurde, Zack, gleich ist es so, achja,
das war Impfung stellst, das ist, ok, 19.
August, 19.
August, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob das die erste oder die zweite war, ja, mir, ich
hab eh was mit mir wächst geschrieben, aber das findet, ist ja auch egal, war eh ein dummer
Witz, ich hab mir einfach eine WLAN-Antenne unter das Hemd gesteckt und hab gesagt, mir
wächst Antenne aus dem Arm, richtig low IQ, low brain Witz, so, wie gut funktioniert
das Qn mit Freunden, naja, wenn du nicht irgendwelche Errorfehler beim Einloggen bekommst, eigentlich
ganz gut, es gibt leider kein Verlassen mit Lobby, sehr merkwürdig, wie sie das geregelt
haben, ja, es äh mich auch nicht, was hältst du von Far Cry 6, ich wollte es mir eigentlich
kaufen, aber nachdem ich mir die Reviews durchgelesen hab zu Far Cry 6, bin ich zu dem Schluss
gekommen, ich will Far Cry 6 nicht haben, nein, hab ich nicht, kenn ich nur ein paar
Videos zu, die XP Booster, weil ich denke, das haben sie gefixt, wahrscheinlich, ja gut,
was ich übrigens witzig fand, ich hab auf Reddit einen Post gefunden, ähm, ich dachte
erster mein das ernst, wie findest du Battlefield Portal, es ist halt auch noch broken, wie
so viel es in dem Game, Bad Company 2 kannst du nicht spielen, weil die Drohne nicht killbar
ist, also in Bad Company 2 kannst du easy 100 plus Kills machen, indem du einfach in den
URV reingehst, in die URV Drohne, und du bist unzerstörbar, also du kannst die Drohne nicht
töten, oder du brauchst so viel Damage, dass keiner macht, also du kannst die ganze Runde
mit der Drohne rumfliegen und alles killen, die macht auch viel mehr Damage, die Drohne
war in Bad Company 2 eigentlich gar nicht so gut, die hast du zweimal gehitted, oder einmal
gehitted und dann war sie kaputt, ja, aber ich hab gestern einen Post gefunden, das
fand ich eigentlich ganz witzig, auf Reddit, und ich dachte, ich dachte erst, der meint
das ernst, wobei es steht hier nirgendswo drunter, dass das Satire ist, aber ich geh
mal davon aus, das fand ich eigentlich relativ gut, weil das so ein bisschen die Sache verarscht,
was da gelaufen ist, also er erzählt hier sowas in der Richtung, also als Battlefield
Spieler, er liebt es, dass Battlefield 2042 so inclusive ist, und dass so viel gemacht
wurde, um hier Toxic Verhalten zu eliminieren, so, was ich aber witzig fand, bis wohin ich
geglaubt habe, dass das echt sein könnte, ach ja, hier, hier, guck mal, die Leute haben
meinen Twitter-Post gefunden, ja, Low IQ-Witz, ich weiß, shit mir weg, ist was aus dem Arm,
ja, ist auch noch so billig gemacht, zumindest, das war am Juni, das heißt, 16. August war
die zweite Impfung, das bedeutet, ich hab jetzt seit, auf jeden Fall definitiv noch
nicht seit 6 Monaten, also seit 3 Monaten hab ich meine Impfung am Start, ok, so, also
bis wohin ich geglaubt habe, ist, hier, ist das, woran er schreibt, er wird sich freuen
über SPMM, aber was ich halt richtig gut fand, ist das, ist der Intro-Satz von, also
ist hier der, nicht der Intro, der, ähm, der zweite Absatz, genau, der zweite Absatz,
weil, das ist genau der Grund, warum die Games heute teilweise so sind, wie sie sind, ja,
er sagt natürlich, natürlich ist das Troll, also ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das Troll
ist, aber er schreibt hier halt sowas wie, ja, in den letzten Battlefields war ich immer
am unteren, bin ich immer am unteren Ende des Scoreboards rumgegräbst und es hat wirklich
mein Selbstvertrauen und meinen Spaß am Spiel zerstört, oder beschädigt, oder denke
ich mir halt so, genau das ist der Grund, warum es das nicht mehr gibt in dem Spiel,
das ist der Grund, die wollen einfach nicht, dass vielleicht Leute, die in Zukunft noch
Skins kaufen, oder Battle Passes kaufen, oder Packs kaufen, oder In-Game-Shops kaufen, abgeschreckt
werden dadurch, dass das Spiel ihnen zeigt, hey Alter, du bist scheiße in dem Game, und
ja, das ist kein gutes Gefühl, ich glaube jeder kennt das, du spielst, gibst dir Mühe,
aber du guckst dir deine Stats an und siehst, mein Gott bin ich kacke, das kommt halt nur
mal vor, und natürlich ist das kein so schönes Gefühl, aber ich muss halt auch mal sagen,
es gibt in nahezu jedem Game, für jeden, und ich sag mal auch jetzt mal ganz, ich lehne
mich da jetzt ein bisschen weiter, auch aus dem Fenster, auch für jeden, also für jeden
und jeden Alters die Möglichkeit da was dran zu ändern, du wirst vielleicht nicht mehr,
wenn du 60 plus bist und ein paar Stunden Battlefield spielst, aber Battlefield ist jetzt auch kein
super competitive Game, du wirst vielleicht nicht top 0,1%, aber wenn du ein bisschen
übst und mit Hirn spielst, da wirst du über kurz oder lang, wenn du einfach nur dran bleibst
und regelmäßig spielst, ganz passabel gut, du wirst nicht alles krass wegauen, aber du
wirst, du bist okay dann irgendwann, du bist ganz gut, du musst einfach nur dranbleiben,
sich Gedanken drüber machen, okay was macht man denn jetzt dummes, zum Beispiel, ich pick
immer eine Klasse die schlecht ist und renne in die Gegner rein, dann sollte man es vielleicht
mal anders machen, muss ich einfach gedenken machen, so und was ich halt witzig finde ist,
dass das genau der Grund ist, warum die solche Spiele so machen und so Dinger wie Scoreboard
entfernt, weil es Leute gibt, die wirklich, das hier ist jetzt zwar Satire, aber Leute,
die wirklich so drauf sind und naja, man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen, es ist gut, dass man
vielleicht kein, wie genau kann man selbst vertrauen oder so, ich meine es ist ja klar,
warum sollte man selbst vertrauen in einem Game, also in seine Fähigkeiten in einem
Game haben, wenn man immer der letzte im Scoreboard ist, wo kommt, wo soll dieses Selbstvertrauen
herkommen, so nach dem Motto, ja ich bin schlecht, dementsprechend habe ich kein Selbstvertrauen
in meine Skills in dem Game, ja richtig, du bist halt auch schlecht, das muss das Game
doch nicht kaschieren und das ist halt das, was versucht wird und ja, wie gesagt, kann
sich oft genossen haben, falls das Thema klippt, ich weiß, dass der Post wahrscheinlich,
die Chebatest Verarschung ist, ja, aber es gibt halt wirklich so Leute, ja, dann schreibt
ihr noch was über Any Chat und sonst was, der Rest ist im Prinzip das gleiche, das ist
halt ein riesen Chebatest Post, ja, das ist übrigens auch der gleiche Grund, warum, also
meine Vermutung, warum man den Chat entfernt hat, es gibt ja keinen Chat mehr, also keinen
globalen Chat, ich habe das in meinem letzten Video vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich
ausgedrückt, ups, das ist das falsche, ich habe das in meinem letzten Video vielleicht
ein bisschen missverständlich ausgedrückt, ich habe gesagt, es gibt keinen Chat und dann
habe ich irgendwie erst zwei Sätze danach gesagt, Global Chat, ja und das haben die
meisten Leute natürlich nicht verstanden, weil das ist ja YouTube und die haben dann
reingeschrieben, ha, null, er sagt, es gibt keinen Chat und 8.30 wird genau ein Chat eingeplendet
und sowas, ja, das dachte ich mir, das war doof, aber gut, kann man nichts dran machen,
die Leute hören ja eh nicht genau zu und ja, es gibt tatsächlich keinen Chat, es gibt
keinen global Chat und warum gibt es keinen global Chat, damit die Leute durch sinnloses
Geflame nicht abgeschreckt werden können und warum gibt es kein Scoreboard, naja, unter
anderem, dass du nicht mehr die Leute flamen kannst, die scheiße sind in deinem Team, wobei
man halt auch mal wirklich sagen muss, meiner Ansicht nach ist es in Battlefield gar nicht
so schlimm gewesen, also, habt, ich weiß nicht, ob einer von euch mal beispielsweise
Overwatch ranked gespielt hat, du kannst jedes, jedes, du kannst jedes, sag mal mal,
relativ competitive Game nehmen, was ein ranked System hat, von CS bis Overwatch bis Rainbow
6, alter, die, das Toxic Level in Overwatch ranked oder CS oder was auch immer ist ja
mal um, um Universen größer als das Toxic Level in Battlefield, also klar hast du in
Battlefield im allgemeinen Chat immer mal irgendwie diese üblichen, you suck, hier,
was weiß ich, which brain dead is flying, Jett oder sowas, ja, hast du immer, aber
insgesamt ist diese Toxicity in Battlefield im Vergleich zu anderen so PvP Multiplayer
Spielen ziemlich gering, das liegt aber auch daran, weil Battlefield nicht so krass competitive
ist, in Battlefield ist es eigentlich den meisten Leuten ziemlich egal, ob sie jetzt
super krasse KD haben oder nicht, klar, wenn man den Tryhard Modus einschaltet, ja, und
dann sinnlos von irgendwas um die Ecke gebästet, ist es schon, ist es schon, genau, das kommt
nämlich auch dazu, dass Battlefield ziemlich, so ziemlich, wie soll man sagen, ja, ein bisschen,
bisschen, ein bisschen Hirn ausschalten und halt Battlefield spielen ist, das ist nicht
so ultra Tryhard, wie du jetzt beispielsweise in Overwatch ranked, CS ranked, Rainbow 6,
was auch immer rank machst, du joinst einfach einen Server, der dir vom Setting her gut
gefällt, manche Leute spielen auch komplett auf Support, ja, es gibt, es gab Leute, die
waren top auf, nicht viele, aber das gab's, die haben top Scoreboard und haben einen Kill,
haben aber irgendwie 60 Revives oder sowas, das wird, das wird es in der Form natürlich
in Battlefield 2042 nicht geben und also diese ganze Toxicity in Battlefield, klar, die gibt's,
aber die ist verschwindend gering und was man ja auch nicht vergessen darf, es wird
zwar immer gesagt, das ist alles so toxic, aber umgedreht kommt das auch vor, also ich
hab's, ich hab's ehrlich gesagt, würde mich mal interessieren, ich hab's öfters gesehen,
dass die Leute im Chat sich zwar schon so ein bisschen geärgert haben, aber eher so
auf Basis, das war nice, was weiß ich, wenn dich einer mit dem LLV across the map geschottet
hat, dann hat er irgendwie einer geschrieben LLV Abuse oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung,
ja, manche schreiben auch einfach nice shot oder sowas in der Richtung, also das hab
ich viel, viel öfters gesehen als toxic Geschister im Chat, also ja, wie gesagt, dieser Post
ist nicht ernst gemeint, aber es gibt halt wirklich so Leute, tja, so ist es halt, was
zum, kann das sein, dass der in seinen Videos immer mit GTA mit dem Motorrad im Kreis fährt,
das ist jedes Mal so oder, ist das so, wirklich, gab's da einen Patch in der Zeit, wo ich
oft war, das ist doch Chebat, oder, das ist doch massive Chebat bestimmt wieder, nein,
hat's nicht, das ist Chebat, das ist einfach nur Chebat, nein, gab's nicht, das ist Chebat,
das ist einfach richtig krasses Chebat mal wieder, bist schon mit dem Overcraft die
Fassade der Hochhäuser, ne, aber ich bin schon mit dem Overcraft von Hochhaus zu Hochhaus
gejumpt, naja, eigentlich wollte ich Portal streamen und ich wollte versuchen, ob was
möglich ist, mit Tricks in Portal Nosha TDM mit Killstreaks zu bauen, ich weiß, dass es
prinzipiell, also dass es nicht so einfach unterstützt wird, also du kannst nicht einfach
Nosha TDM machen und im Editor dann irgendwie Killstreaks hinzufügen, ne, das gibt's nicht,
aber ich hab mir überlegt, je nachdem, was möglich ist, ja, ob man beispielsweise irgendwie
mitbekommt, wenn du Objekte zerstörst auf der Map, ob man darauf reagieren kann oder
was auch immer, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, das doch, genau, das meine ich ja, das will
ich ja machen, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, dass man so eine Art Nosha TDM mit Killstreaks
baut, das wird mich interessieren, ich glaube, das probieren wir heute im Stream aus im Portal
Editor, ich hab mir das schon überlegt, also man könnte, also du kannst natürlich nichts
in das Spiel reinmachen, was es nicht gibt, jetzt schon, ne, also kannst du keine eigenen
Models oder so machen, aber was man zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich machen kann ist, oder hoffe
ich mal, also wenn man zum Beispiel im Logic Editor sagen kann, wenn man die Stats abfragen
kann von einem Spieler, und daraufhin dann zum Beispiel sagen kann, nach vier Kills
gibt es irgendwie, spawnet eine Drohne oder sowas, irgendwo auf der Map, sowas so Dinger,
also, na klar, wir kriegen damit jetzt keine Nuke eingebaut oder so bei 24 Kills, aber
ich will einfach mal probieren, ob man sowas wie Nosha TDM mit Killstreaks spawnen kann,
es wird nicht perfekt sein, es wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich krass balanced und gut
spielbar sein, ich will einfach mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, ja, das kannst du machen,
aber wie gesagt, du kriegst da halt nicht irgendwie die extra Video-Sequenz oder sowas
für rein, ja, das könnte man machen, kannst das ganze Team killen nach 24 Kills, man könnte
zum Beispiel auch Smoke zum Beispiel spawnen, und da müsste man das halt irgendwie auf der
Map markieren können, das ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das möglich ist, weil ich glaube,
Portal ist halt rein Server-seitig, das heißt, du kannst, du müsstest irgendwas auswerten,
was Server-seitig erkennbar ist, wo es den Smoke spawnen soll oder so, das müssen wir
ausprobieren, das probieren wir nachher mal aus, die Anforderung ist eigentlich fast
egal, weil auf meinem Rechner, der schlechter ist als aktuellen Rechner, läuft es besser
als auf aktuellen Rechnern, also beispielsweise auf meinem, 8700K mit 1080Ti läuft das Game
so mit 90 FPS und auf neuen Rechnern, die irgendwie einen fetten Ryzen haben, 3080,
läuft das Spiel teilweise mit 45 FPS, also es ist richtig holprig, weiß nicht, was die
Papa Dice gemacht haben, aber jetzt kommen wir auf ein paar Videos, mit was fangen wir
an?
PS5 has been hacked, unexpected home automation ideas, das müssen wir, ich hab den Anfang
geguckt, ich bin wieder vom Glauben abgefallen Leute, das ist so, ich guck mir mittlerweile
richtig gerne so Verschwörungstheorien-Debunked-Videos an, weil da erfährt man, wie bescheuert einfach
manche Leute sind, das ist so dumm, Alter, es ist unglaublich, wie ernst sie das auch
teilweise meinen, übrigens habt ihr das hier gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob das einfach nur
gut geschnitten ist und das nicht stimmt, aber wenn das stimmt, ist es schon, sehr offensichtlicher
Rip-Off, guckt euch das mal an, das links, nur das ihr es wisst, das erkennt man erst
am Ende, das links ist Battlefield 2042, das rechts ist ein anderes Game, ich weiß nicht,
ob das echt ist, ob er das einfach nur gut geschnitten hat, es ist halt die Frage, wer
wen Rip-Off hat, war das zuerst oder das zuerst, weiß nicht, nein überhaupt nicht, nein, es
hat null mit Bad Company 2 zu tun, das Bad Company 2 in Portal, du hast Jump, also du
hast nicht die normalen BC-2-Sprunggeschichten, du hast die Sprunganimationen, du hast keine
Perks, die Spawn-Points sind anders, die Helis fliegen ganz anders bzw. sie können
viel höher und weiter fliegen, du kannst sie schlechter treffen, die Waffen-Balance
stimmt hinten und vorne nicht, Waffen fehlen, Attachments fehlen, Gadgets fehlen glaube
ich teilweise auch, wie gesagt Spawn-Points sind anders, Timings von Gadgets sind anders,
ja, also nein, es hat null, also man davon habe gesehen, dass im Prinzip außer zwei Maps
und ein paar Waffen nichts drinne ist, nein, es ist komplett anders als BC-2, das fühlt
sich an, wisst ihr wie es sich anfühlt, Bad Company 2 in Portal fühlt sich an wie diese
Videos, ich habe Ocarina of Time in Unreal nachgebaut, es fühlt sich an, als hat jemand
versucht Bad Company 2 in etwas nachzubauen, was nicht Bad Company 2 ist und sich nicht
anfühlt wie Bad Company 2, Alter, heute ist ja wirklich Monka Corona, boah, ja, die Strafe
ist, wobei, da habe ich gar nicht so genau drauf geachtet, aber du kannst dich halt nicht
hinlegen und sowas, gibt es noch Bad Company 2 Server, ja, so zwei, zwei drei hält sie
echt den Grenzen, ich hoffe aktuell hat das Spiel keinen Inhalt, es gibt nichts, es gibt
wie viele Maps gibt es, sieben Maps glaube ich, aber es gibt nichts, das Spiel hat keinen
Inhalt, also Portal ist jetzt ja auch nicht die Entschuldigung für alles, das Spiel
hat keinen Inhalt, es gibt sieben Maps und 128 Spiele, ok, es gibt zwei Spielmodi, ansonsten
gibt es nix, also ich weiß jetzt zwar nicht, was das da mit dem zu tun hat, aber das letzte
Spiel, ja, die sind ein bisschen größer gemacht, stimmt, ja, das stimmt, was ist das
eigentlich, eine schlechte KQW Kopie jetzt von Twitch, dann aber doch, dann doch lieber
das Original oder, was haben denn ältere Spiele im Inhalt gehabt, außer die Kampagne,
ok, an die Kampagne habe ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, aber Kampagne ist natürlich auch
ein wichtiger Punkt, vergleich das mal mit Battlefield 4, Battlefield 4 hatte, was weiß
ich, wie viele Spielmodi, also im Kern und nicht einfach so, jo, jo, ob der Portal könnte
machen, was er wollte, im Kern Battlefield 4, was hatten wir, acht verschiedene Spielmodi,
ob jetzt alle so gut waren, sei mal dahingestellt, aber du hattest wenigstens, du hattest wenigstens
so Sachen wie TDM dabei, du hattest Rush dabei, du hattest zwar Maps, die waren für
alles, aber die waren wenigstens sinnvoll angepasst für die unterschiedlichen Spielmodi, was
jetzt ja in Breakthrough gar nicht der Fall ist, Breakthrough hast du discardet, hast du
einfach eine flache Ebene für den ersten Punkt mit zwei Fahnen drauf, du hattest komplett
ein eigenes Game, was Attachments an Fahrzeugen angeht, vergleich das mal mit Battlefield
4, Battlefield 4 konntest du Fahrzeuge mega krass customisieren, auch Waffen und alles
mögliche in der Richtung hattest du, was weiß ich, wie viele Waffen hat Battlefield
4, 80, wenn du mal die ganzen Gadgets und Dinge, die mit den DLCs dazugekommen sind
nimmst, also ultra viel und super customizable auch, dazu kam halt, dass die Spiele Tiefgang
hatten, man kann das gar nicht so sehr quantifiziert an irgendwelchen Waffen und Gadgets festmachen,
aber die Spiele hatten halt eben richtig Tiefgang und du hast bei Battlefield 4 auch am Anfang
gemerkt, ok, die haben sich Gedanken gemacht, du hast dann beispielsweise Stellen gehabt
oder mir fällt jetzt ein gutes Beispiel ein aus Battlefield 3, ja, du entdeckst auf Maps
in Battlefield 3 immer noch heute Dinger, die dir auffallen, wo du sagst, boah, da haben
die dran gedacht, ja, zum Beispiel, wenn du auf, nimm mal Grand Bazaar, wenn du Rush an
der ersten Base, ist schwer zu beschreiben, da wo die Leute immer C4 runter werfen vom
Haus, ja, da steht ein Container und da kannst du in den Gang auf die andere Seite gucken,
aber die haben da einen Pony, oder so eine Mauer, dir so davor gestellt, dass du genau
an die Stelle nicht gucken kannst, auf die es ankommt, um da rüber zu crossen über
das, das ist richtig Big Brain, also das Spiel hatte wirklich Tiefgang und das ist da, also
wüsste nicht, wo das da sein soll, zweite Base, nein, das war die erste, das war, das
ist dort erste Rush Basis auf, ich meine übrigens nicht Bazaar, ich meine Zen Crossing, nicht
zweite Base, lul, ich meine Zen Crossing, ich hab mich versprochen, Zen Crossing, wo
die Leute C4 runterschmeißen, da steht so ein Container und da kannst du genau so durch
gucken, dass du nicht das siehst, wo die Spieler quasi rüber crossen und so, das ist richtig
Big Brain gemacht und das ist mir auch erst jetzt später aufgefallen und das sind einfach
so Details und Tiefgang, das hat Battlefield 2042 nicht, plus halt auch so rein in Zahlen
der Content, du hast sieben große Maps, das ist aber wirklich das einzige, was dieses Spiel
an, ja wirklich, an viel Content zu bieten, also es gibt viel Gelände, es gibt viel Gelände,
aber ja okay, das hat das Spiel, das hat wirklich Gelände, aber alles in allem an Tiefgang,
also allein schon, dass du nur zwei Spielmodi hast und Breakthrough spielt sich in der Hälfte
der Maps richtig beschissen auf ein paar ganz gut, also da fehlt so viel, das Spiel hat
eigentlich keinen Inhalt, die viele aus Battlefield 3 Mitarbeiter noch arbeiten, tja wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr so viele, ja, also guck mal, allein schon, du siehst das doch hier, Battlelog Brows,
oder Battlefield 4, allein schon, allein schon hier, was du hier alles für Dinge hast, gut,
wir nehmen jetzt mal, wir lassen jetzt mal die DLC Maps mal weg, die gibt's natürlich
nicht, aber ich mein, du hast allein schon in Battlefield 4 deutlich mehr Maps, das ist
hier eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, nein
das nicht, du hast zwölf Maps, okay, die sind, kann man sagen, ist ungefähr even, weil
die Maps größer sind, aber größere Maps ja nicht gleich besser, allein schon die Spielmodi,
die du hast, wo ist das alles, wo ist das alles, du hast die Möglichkeit, keine Stats
zu sehen von dir, du siehst keine Stats, also es ist aktuell sehr wenig Inhalt, klar du
kannst sagen, du hast Hazard Zone, aber ich sag's euch wie es ist, Hazard Zone wird, weil
es nicht, also man muss ja das Spiel dafür kaufen, dass man Hazard Zone spielen kann,
im Kern eigentlich ganz cool, aber dadurch, dass es nicht free to play ist, gehe ich davon
aus, dass das innerhalb von zwei, drei Monaten komplett tot ist, du siehst es ja auch, der
Unterschied ist, wenn du, geh mal hier, zum Beispiel so eines der beliebtesten Sachen,
so eines meiner Lieblingsmaps in, nehmen wir mal meine Lieblingsmaps aus Battlefield 4,
uns einmal das hier, natürlich locker spielt, locker spielt irgendwie jeder, wo ist es denn,
locker, ah nee, Operation Spint heißt das hier auf Deutsch, hab ich ja ganz verdrängt,
das ja hieß ja Operation Spint, Shanghai fand ich tatsächlich auch ganz cool, der Morgen
der Mire, der war auch nice, ja, ich finde Hainan Resort ist tatsächlich sogar ganz
gut mit Battlefield 20, 42 Maps zu vergleichen, das ist auch relativ offen und viel Gelände,
aber trotzdem durchdachter, so das waren jetzt so mit meinen Lieblingsmaps aus Battlefield
4 und wenn du hier gute Runden hattest, gerade auf locker, ja stimmt, Gollmoth war auch
nice, du hattest dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, 100 Kills oder so, 100 plus Kills, wenn
das längere Runde Conquest locker war und was hast du bei einer längeren Runde Conquest
Battlefield 20, 42, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade Hovercraft Abused in deinem Kreis fährst,
du hast, keine Ahnung, 25 Kills oder so, wenn du richtig abgegangen bist, weil viel los
war, 25, 30 Kills, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, das ist einfach so viel Leerlauf und
nix los, tja, spiel immer noch Leute, aber nicht so viele, hält sich in Grenzen, ich
bin wirklich sauer gerade, ja und in Battlefield 4 fühlt sich wenigstens so an, es hittet
dort wo du hinschießt, ja, die ganzen Attachments, ja, das war in Battlefield 4.
ja gut, das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgezählt, weil das könnte ja in 20, 42 auch noch
kommen, achja und das Menü ist auch kacke, ja das stimmt, habt ihr mal versucht Attachments
zu tauschen, die Position von Attachments zu tauschen, das ist so painstamp, dann fix
dein Aim, ja habe ich schon gemacht, trotzdem habe ich übelste Schwierigkeiten, was wahrscheinlich
daran liegt, dass die Frame Rate so inkonsistent ist, also ich habe noch in kaum einem Game
so große Probleme gehabt, einfach nur auf dem Gegner zu bleiben, sieht man doch hier
auch übelst krass mit der Pistole, guckt mal, ich meine, ich habe bestimmt jetzt nicht
das super krasse hier 18-jähriger Pro Gamer Aim mehr, aber manche Sachen sind wirklich
painstampig, das geht ja alles noch irgendwie so, hittet nicht, pass mal auf Pistole, pass
mal auf gleich Pistole, so, the fuck, ich habe übelste Probleme auf diesen fucking Gegner
zu kommen, null, was übrigens aber auch an einer Sache liegt, guckt mal, der rennt jetzt
hier weiter und instant, also du hast kaum einen Übergang von einer Animation in die
andere, also der springt quasi von nach links zu hoch, jetzt bin ich nach rechts, also ich
habe wirklich Probleme auf dem Target zu bleiben hier, legt aber bestimmt an mir, will ich
gar nicht mal so sehr aufs Game schieben, lustigerweise in anderen Games ist es nicht
so, auf der Xbox läuft das Game gut, mit wieviel Frames läuft das auf der Xbox, 30 oder
schaffen sie die 60 zu halten, zenerastische 24.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass er das mit den Controller-Settings zeigt, der zeigt bestimmt
Controller-Settings mit zweimal auf 100% stellen und diese Controller-Aim ausmachen, gehe
ich mal davon aus, dass er das jetzt zeigt, das ist ja bekannt, das hier, ne, ne, ne, unter
advanced ist das, falls er das zeigt, ja, das hier, das hier muss man machen, unter Controller,
weil das wohl, weil das hat Auswirkungen auf den PC, du musst, du musst unter, ne, Moment,
das stimmt nicht, der muss unter Controller machen, Controller, ja, das ist egal, das
ist da, ja, komm, das ist egal, unter advanced ist das, hier, das musst du machen, du musst
das ausmachen und das auf 100% stellen, das hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen Auswirkungen
auf Maus und Tastatur, warum auch immer, man weiß es nicht, das ist richtig, richtig, richtig
fail, was ich zu Battlefield sage, wie gesagt, ich habe mich jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber
ausgelassen, aber ich würde noch warten, ich würde noch warten, bis da noch irgendwas
rauskommt, so, gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an, also, nein, ich habe nur zufällig, zufällig
das gleiche Logo und höre mich ähnlich an, aber ich bin ja Wubblos, ich kann gar nicht
Max FPS sein, oh, das Scam Train ist am Start, danke für den Sub, th-man87, jetzt gucken,
ich habe bestimmt wieder irgendwelche Subs übersehen, weil ich so um Schwätzen war,
twins83, danke für den Sub, habe ich nicht gesehen, elhambi auch hier, neun Monate, huge,
also eher noch abwarten, bis mehr Content kommt oder ist der Drops doch schon gelutscht,
kommt drauf an, wie scharf du bist, um das zu spielen willst, also ich würde auf jeden
Fall warten jetzt noch, worpel hat Subscribed, danke für den Sub und Michael 50 Billionen
vor zwei Stunden habe ich gar nicht gesehen, Massive, ne, habe ich nicht gesehen, ja, ja,
das ist auch eine Möglichkeit, du kannst EA Play Pro oder wie das heißt holen, da kannst
du es anspielen, ich habe mich hier oben benannt, ich heiße auf Twitch schon immer so, nichts
Neues, Sauhaus Master, danke für den huge Massive, zack, aber ich finde meine Emotes
gerade nicht, fuck, alles klar, so jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein paar Videos an, was haben wir
hier, Ripoff Video, haben wir geguckt, wow, was passiert werden, wenn wir eine Atombombe
auf den Mond schießen, alles klar, das muss ich wissen, so PS5 has been hacked, Unexpected,
jetzt mal, wir gucken jetzt erstmal, was angeblich gehackt wurde auf der PS5, weil ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass es wieder komplettes G-Bate Video ist, wobei der eigentlich ganz
gute Videos macht, komplettes G-Bate Video ist und eigentlich gar nix passiert ist, Ah,
so waits, also er zeigt, was wurde gehackt an der PS5, chat, wart ihr das etwa, Fail Overflow,
nicht zu verwechseln mit Live Overflow, warte, oh, ey, danke für den Sub, hm, ja, ja, ja,
auf, zeig her, was gibt's, ah, yes, Obvious, Obvious, alles klar, yep, Obvious, komplett
klar, warum das, warum das Probleme macht, of course, Debug Settings,
wird das Development Kit für die PS5 wirklich so kacke aus, na gut, das war halt lange vor,
wahrscheinlich schon am Start, bevor die Konsole am Start war, weil die müssen ja was
entwickeln in der Zeit, wie das selbst noch quasi nicht Final fertig ist, das sieht eher
aus wie so ein alter Videorecorder oder so, war kurz der Praktikant aus dem 3D-Drucker
rausgeholtes Gehäuse, ja, wahrscheinlich hat er keinen Bock, die Sony-Anwälte am Hals
zu haben, ich hoffe, das lässt er sich wenigstens gut bezahlen, wenn er das Sony verriegt,
warum lag das?
Legitimate now i think others are probably going to start taking a look at this
Warum leckt es?
Posted on twitter, but if this wasn't enough a second blow to sony
Ja also ich mein guck mal hier das ist so offensichtlich dass das sony nicht beim entwickeln schon aufgefallen ist
Ich meine wenn man hier guck mal allein schon wenn man hier an e6 an a0 h startet
Ist doch klar dass das nicht funktionieren kann
Ich weiß nicht warum das sony nicht gleich klar war
from legendary group fail overflow with a tweet that showed a
Nene point oh three firmware file and they quickly confirmed via a follow-up tweet that all ps5 root keys had been extracted
Oh, das ist nice keys mind you can be used das ist das ist nice root keys extracted heißt damit kann man sich selbst eigene
Software signieren so dass sie quasi läuft als wäre es offiziell
To both encrypt and decrypt data and all this was done via software in other words
There's no hardware dumper or anything that was sold and onto the board now
This is a pretty massive discovery and it has shades of failover flow totally pwning the ps3 all those years ago
And with a private key you can sign things
But
Just like the flows find failover flow were not disclosing their methods
So we'll need to wait and see if there is ever a public release or at least a write-up of this
My guess is that they will probably
Take this exploit. They've found and refine it to enable Linux to boot on the ps5
This is something that has been a motivator for
Overflow
for many many years and the ability to boot into linux
Also dass sie das hinkriegen by them on many different consoles over the years now
I did talk to the flow briefly because I wanted to get some clarification on a couple of things and the big question
I asked was are these two exploits connected in any way and he mentioned that they were not these are two
Completely separate things aha and I want to stress. This is a big blow to Sony that have left themselves
Man muss überlegen die ps5 ist ja eigentlich erst ein jahr alt bei der ps3
Bei der ps3 hat es glaube ich fünf jahre gedauert oder so
These types of security flaws now of course it's almost certain that a firmware update
Can and probably will address both. Wobei was witzig bei der ps3 war sobald
Und sony hat ja irgendwann gesagt sie stellen den linux support ein für die ps3 und zwei wochen später ging
Dann irgendwie der erste hack online, but the damage has been done with a decrypted firmware
it's now possible to reverse engineer and locate other potential exploits and
Additional weak points now to be very clear right now these discoveries while massive and
Can open up the playstation 5 for homebrew. There's still no way to run
PS 5 homebrew. There's no homebrew enabler. There's no custom firmware. Ja gut das dauert
jahre
Wobei ich halt sagen muss dass seit der ps4 für mich so dieser ansatz von
konsole flaschen homebrew
Ein bisschen gesunken ist weil im prinzip kommen immer mehr games raus damals
Exklusiv waren für die konsole jetzt auch auf dem pc. Guck mal hier der dhl simulator ist jetzt raus
Wie heißt das mit den mit den
dinosaur mit den
Mechanik dinosaurium aloi ist das horizon zero dawn ist raus für den pc
Ja noch viel mehr also vieles kommt ja auf dem pc raus und nachdem ja seit der ps4 und der xbox wie auch immer sie hieß der
vorletzten xbox
Dass mehr oder weniger eh noch pc hardware ist zumindest x86 cpus drinnen
Ist so dieser dieser anreiz finde ich irgendwie geringer als früher
Stimmt gar noch vor kommt auch auf dem pc ja
Still very much in Microsoft hat mit exclusives ja noch weniger
Über anchatten auf pz exploits will er gett released in the public maybe they've been submitted to sony
Und wir don't know if any of this will even matter once sony
puts out some firmware updates
But the good news is these exploits exist on four point oh three at least so if you ask someone that it's interested potentially in
A jailbreak or an exploit for ps5
dann würde ich empfehlen, wenn ihr es könnt, und ich verstehe definitiv, dass es sehr schwierig ist,
hat dadurch der PC endlich gewonnen. Ich glaube, eigentlich gibt es da gar keinen Krieg im eigentlichen Sinne, und ich glaube, das ist auch nichts, was irgendwie von der einen oder anderen Seite endgültig gewonnen werden kann. Das hängt davon ab, wie sich das in Zukunft entwickelt. Also das kann man so nicht sagen. Ich denke, es wird sowohl Konsolen als auch PC auf nicht so ganz absehbare Zeit weiterhin parallel geben.
Weil Big Stunks werden immer noch auf der Konsole gemacht. Nicht mal so krass wie 2010 oder so, aber immer noch.
Okay, kommt da noch was? Ah ja, hier. Ja, garantiert. Das war ja auch ein geiler Satz. Irgendwann wird auf der PS5 mal was passieren, aber es ist noch überhaupt nicht absehbar wann.
Ah ja, yes, gut zu wissen. Oh, guck mal hier, würden die völlig weebs unter uns wieder. Was sonst?
Okay, da. Okay, da kommt nichts mehr. Da kommt nichts mehr. Das war es im Prinzip. Ich glaube, mehr muss man sich da näher angucken.
Refreshen. Vielleicht empfiehlt uns ja YouTube noch irgendwas, was taugt. Ultra realistic Battlefield. Okay, zeig her.
Ich glaube, das kommt, wenn man sich zu lange nicht bewegt. Gerade gesehen auf YouTube Linus hat wohl ein Meeting mit einem YouTube Manager im nächsten Jahr.
Ja, schön. Was soll dabei rauskommen? Ich weiß nicht. Habt ihr schon deaktivierte Likes und Dislikes? Also ich habe es auf dem zweiten Rechner, zweiten Browser. Hab ich schon.
Ist bei euch schon aktiviert? Ich mache euch gerade mal einen Screenshot. So sieht das aus.
Sag habe ich gerade gesehen, weil habe ich auf dem zweiten, zweiten Bildschirm offen. So sieht das. So sieht das. So sieht das dann aus. Guckt mag ich nicht.
Kannst du noch drücken und du hast nur noch nur noch Likes. Das ist eh so ein Ding. Guckt euch mal das offizielle Video an zu den.
Ich muss. Man findet das nicht gescheit über die über die Suche. Wahrscheinlich hat YouTube das nicht suchen kann. Aber ich habe es ja verlinkt.
Guckt euch mal das offizielle Video an zu diesem Dislike abschalten. Stellt euch mal vor, dieses Video hätte jetzt keine Dislikes.
Dann würdet ihr sehen, dass es ein Video mit 1,2 Millionen aufrufen und 12.000 Likes. Wenn ihr euch jetzt super gut auskennt und YouTube so quasi schon in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen ist,
dann würdet ihr wahrscheinlich sagen 1,2 Millionen Aufrufe und quasi davon streichst ihr einfach mal ein paar Nullen weg. Dann bist du ja auch bei 12K.
Das ist vom Like zu Viewverhältnis vielleicht. Aber vielleicht ist es einfach ein Thema, wo die Leute nicht so viel interagieren mit. Man weiß nicht.
Also man könnte schon sagen, ja, das sieht nicht so aus, als wäre das nicht gut bewertet bei 1,2 Millionen Views zu 12.000 Likes.
Aber welcher normaler YouTube Zuschauer weiß denn sowas?
Es ist genau, es ist etwas Sus, das stimmt. Aber so wirklich wissen tust du es nicht.
Ich mache mal das Video bei mir kurz auf dem anderen Rechner auf, da sehen wir ja, wie es dann aussieht. Ja, super, ne?
Zack, ich zeige euch Screenshot.
So sieht das auf dem anderen Rechner bei mir aus.
So sieht es auf dem anderen Rechner aus.
Wer ist denn so big brain im YouTube Game drinnen, dass er erkennt, dass das hier zu dem hier bedeutet, das Video hat 90.000 Dislikes?
Das sieht eigentlich für jemand, der nicht so für 99% der YouTube Zuschauer sieht das so aus, als wäre dieses Video halt beliebt.
Da ist eigentlich nichts dran auszusetzen.
Und in Wirklichkeit sieht es halt so aus. So, mal ernsthaft.
Das sieht doch jetzt einfach viel positiver aus, als es irgendwie aufgenommen wurde.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendjemand erkennt, dass das hier nicht zueinander passt.
Du stellst random Behauptungen auf, welche denn?
Ja, also das ist wirklich einfach, zack.
5 Sterne, gut, dass sie keine Sternebewertung mehr machen wollen. Ich persönlich fand die Sternebewertung auch cool.
Aber das kann ich noch nachvollziehen, aber das hier ist doch, das ist doch scheiße.
Ich kann euch eh sagen, was passieren wird. Genau das, was der Mark schreibt, da gibt es dann Sachen, Kommentare, use me as a dislike-Button und sowas.
Nee, es gibt ja keine Alternative zu YouTube, deswegen könnt ihr auch so Zeug machen.
Was kommt als nächstes? Kommentare ausstellen, weil sonst könnte man sich in den Kommentaren darüber auslassen.
Und es wird definitiv nicht zu dem führen, was man sich denkt.
Sie haben ja gesagt, sie wollen kleine Creator beschützen, was ich ja persönlich einfach für einen vorgeschobenen Grund halte.
In Wirklichkeit geht es darum, dass YouTube unter dem Strich mehr Geld verdient, wie bei allen Sachen.
Weil Dislikes eventuell Leute davon abhalten, was zu gucken. Das ist ja das, was YouTube nicht will.
Und im Endeffekt ist das einfach nur Big Stonks Move von YouTube, nichts anderes.
Ja, und kleine Creator kriegen jetzt halt mehr Hasskommentare, wenn die Leute nicht einfach nur disliken können.
Mark, lädst du YouTube-Videos auf einer altartigen Plattform auch? Nö, das ist das typische Hand-to-Hand Problem.
Dazu kommt ja noch, dass YouTube aktuell eh schon viele blöden Entscheidungen hat.
Zum Beispiel Mid-Roll-Ads, doppelte Ads vor dem Video, teilweise nicht skippbar.
Und für Tutorials ist das komplett dead.
Wenn du Tutorials suchst für irgendwas, das vielleicht jetzt nicht so, wo es vielleicht 5-6 Videos gibt,
und du willst wissen, was was taugt, und die Videos haben halt auch nur 500 Aufrufe, ist halt schwierig.
Ja, by the way, denkt ihr, wisst ihr was ich denke, woran das liegt?
Es liegt unter anderem daran, dass YouTube selbst das ganz gut in Kram passt mit den Dislikes.
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass ein Dislike jemand abhält, davon das Video zu gucken.
Aber ich glaube auch, das liegt unter anderem, unter anderem mit an sowas.
Ich glaube, das liegt unter anderem auch an sowas, weil gerade hier, den missfällt das natürlich schon ziemlich.
Und das ist ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich Dislikes wirklich gut finde,
weil man das Akt, das so das allgemeine Stimmungsbild zu was sehen kann.
Gibt es schon Extensions, die die Zahl anzeigen? Nein, wie willst du das mit Extensions machen?
Extensions hat ja keinen Zugriff auf interne YouTube-Daten.
Du kannst vielleicht ein Plugin machen, was dir anzeigt, wenn die Like zu View Ratio nicht so ganz passt,
dass du das dann anzeigst, aber gerade bei Videos mit wenigen Views klappt das halt auch nicht.
Das stimmt, die Dislikes müssen nicht zwangsläufig was mit dem Video zu tun haben, haben sie aber meistens.
Es gibt Randfälle, wo das nicht so ist, aber dann gibt es trotzdem bessere Möglichkeiten,
als deswegen global auf der gesamten Plattform die Dislikes zu deaktivieren als das Anzeigen.
Ja, das war ja auch geil.
Der ist ja auch guter.
Konnte man die Likes bisher nicht komplett deaktivieren? Doch.
Es gibt ja auch welche, die die Comments deaktivieren.
Oder es gibt Newsseiten, beispielsweise die Tagesschau und so, die prinzipiell Comments und so Zeug deaktivieren.
Was ich übrigens auch eigentlich doof finde, dass es möglich ist, aber gut,
die Comments wollen die Comments nicht moderieren, das verstehe ich irgendwie.
Aber gerade nehmen wir hier mal so aktuelle News.
Ich will gar nicht zu dem eigentlichen Thema sagen, aber nehmen wir mal aktuelle News hier.
Ich finde das immer äußerst interessant zu sehen,
wie denn so die öffentliche Wahrnehmung bestimmter Themen sind.
Das finde ich persönlich sehr interessant, gerade bei Corona News,
wo einem zum Beispiel auffällt, dass die Bildberichterstattung zu Corona
deutlich deutlich mehr Zustimmung hat als beispielsweise die vom ZDF.
Was natürlich daran liegt, dass Bild komplett in die Kerbe haut,
wie das eben viele Leute gerne hätten. Aber okay, das finde ich interessant zu sehen.
Ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, das kann man ja gar nicht beurteilen in dem Fall.
Also für die gesamte Lage, aber es ist interessant zu sehen.
Und das sieht man dann auch nicht mehr und das finde ich wirklich spannend.
Das ist aber das, was wir am nächsten dran haben, oder?
Das ist ja auch schlecht, in dem Fall, klar, du kannst auch auf Twitter gucken,
aber auf Twitter ist es genauso. Aber das ist das, was wir am nächsten dran haben,
sind YouTube Likes und Dislikes, um mal so grob festzustellen, was denkt denn so,
weil YouTube wird von allen verwendet. Klar, du hast sicherlich auch welches gezielt Dislikes,
aber ich finde es schon interessant zu sehen, welche News oder welche Beiträge viele Likes
und viele Dislikes bekommen. Gerade zu Sachen wie aktueller Corona-Lage
finde ich das einfach immer sehr spannend zu sehen.
Die allgemeine Stimmungslage vielleicht nicht, aber die Stimmungslage auf YouTube
und nachdem YouTube wirklich von allen verwendet wird, ist das vielleicht näher dran,
als man denkt. Unabhängig davon, ob es wirklich so ist oder nicht,
es ist auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen.
Das würde funktionieren, das klappt aber ansofern nicht, weil ein großer Teil
dieser Extension verwenden müsste und warum es überhaupt nicht funktioniert ist,
weil die meisten Leute mobile gucken. Auf iOS kannst du es eh vergessen,
auf Android müssten das dann beispielsweise alternative YouTube-Apps anbieten,
weil die offizielle YouTube-App wird es nicht machen.
Ne, das ist bei News nicht so. Also ja, in einer, sagen wir so,
komplett rationalen Welt vielleicht, aber gerade News-Artikel werden eher die News
bewertet als die Berichterstattung oder manchmal auch die Berichterstattung,
wenn es gar so haarsträubend ist. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen,
wie bei aktuellen News die Stimmungslage auf YouTube ist. Und das fällt dann auch weg.
Das ist halt doof.
Leute, ich sage euch jetzt mal, wie es ist. Jeder auf YouTube und jeder auf Twitch
der mehr als fünf Zuschauer hat, der hat einen Großteil, und mit Großteil meine
ich jetzt nicht, das ist falsch, also nicht, ich meine nicht die Mehrzahl,
hat aber einen großen Teil dieser Zuschauer, die gucken zu, also ich sage mal eben,
was weiß ich, 10-20% bei wirklich großen, könnte ich mir durchaus vorkommen,
vor allem großen, kontroversen Channels, aber auch bei kleineren oder auch bei mir.
Ich glaube, es gibt wirklich einen Großteil, nein Großteil ist falsch,
das muss ich anders sagen. Es gibt einen nicht unerheblichen Teil,
so muss ich das sagen. Also es gibt einen Teil, der größer ist, als man vielleicht
dazu denken würde, der nicht zuguckt, weil er das gerne guckt, sondern der zuguckt
und nur darauf wartet, dass der jeweilige YouTuber oder jeweilige Streamer
irgendwas verkackt, um ihn dann zu reporten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es dazu Statistiken gibt, wahrscheinlich hat Twitch
intern sowas, keine Ahnung, aber 100 pro 100, da bin ich mir so sicher,
ich kann es nicht belegen, dass es so ist, ja, aber alles andere würde einfach
nicht zu, keine Ahnung, zu Social Media und live im Internet passen.
Gerade größere Streams und selbst hier, Leute, bei mir jetzt, es gucken hier
bestimmt, wir haben 400 Zuschauer, es gucken bestimmt 20-30 Leute zu,
weil ich sage, Max, der kack spast, ich hoffe, der verkackt und dann reporte
ich ihn jetzt gleich. Ich wette mit euch, das ist so. Die warten einfach nur
drauf, die warten einfach nur drauf, dass ich auf irgendeinen TOS-Link klicke
aus Versehen, irgendwas abspiele, was TOS ist oder was auch immer, dann sagen sie
BÄM, REPORT! Das sieht man ja schon daran, doch ich kann es sogar, er beweist
nicht, aber ich habe ein Indiz dafür, dass das so ist. Und zwar, es gibt
mittlerweile, wie nennt man das überhaupt, Donation Baiting, ich nenne es jetzt
einfach mal, mir fällt kein gescheiter Name dazu ein, ich erkläre euch mal,
um was es geht. Es gibt in letzter Zeit so den kleinen Trend,
es ist nicht wirklich riesengroß, aber es kommt öfters mal vor, dass Leute,
was in den Chat schreiben oder Bits donaten, Name Baiting trifft es
eigentlich ganz gut, dass Leute, was in den Chat schreiben, so nach dem Motto
kannst du mich mal grüßen oder ne Donation schicken mit zwei Centi, die
angezeigt wird oder Channel Points einlösen. Und die haben dann zum
Beispiel eine Name, der ausgesprochen TOS ist, allerdings nicht erkennbar. Ich
kann das jetzt schlecht Beispiele nennen, weil das wäre TOS. Kann man sich
so grob vorstellen? Also, zum Beispiel gibt es dann Schreibweisen von Heil,
als Name hier als Username und diese Leute schreiben dann im Chat, kannst du
mich mal grüßen und dann sagen dann die Leute, ja hallo Heil, weil sie nicht
erkennen, dass damit das eigentlich TOS gemeint ist. Ja, so was, so was, so was,
so was in der Richtung, genau. Und das ist ein kleiner Trend, der leider vorhanden
ist, zum Glück noch nicht so im großen Stil hier. Und allein schon, dass so was
existiert, sieht man, dass es eine nicht unerhebliche Zahl gibt der Leute, die
einfach nur in den Streams sind, weil sie wissen oder sehen wollen, dass der
Streamer es verkackt, um ihn dann zu reporten. So was, genau, so was, genau, so
was, so was in der Richtung. Wobei, wobei das hier, das ist ja noch nicht mal so
wirklich TOS. Also, es gibt Dinge, die gibt es eigentlich gar nicht, aber die
gibt es auf Twitch. Okay, so was schauen wir uns jetzt an, wir müssen jetzt
mal irgendwas, ein paar Bits angucken.
Ich muss euch, ich suche euch mal neben, ich suche euch gerade mal ein Beispiel
raus. Ich habe nämlich auf Twitter letztens so was erst gefunden.
Und letztes Jahr, ne, finde ich nicht mehr. Ja, aber ich habe jetzt letztens ein
richtig schönes Beispiel dazu gesehen auf Twitter. Muss ich mal gucken, ob ich
das finde. So, wir gucken uns aber erstmal irgendwie an. Willkommen, warum, warum
habe ich das hier offen? Hä? Ah, das habe ich gerade angeklickt, wollte ich
gar nicht. Okay, also was schauen wir uns denn jetzt an? Unexpected Smart Doorbell
Home Automation. Okay, nein, Leute, wir müssen uns Verschwörungstheorien
angucken. Ich habe mich am Anfang, ich habe das Video nicht komplett geguckt,
aber so ein bisschen im Anfang und es ist wirklich, es ist so, es ist so massiv
3-Head, das kann ich gar nicht beschreiben, wie die Leute wieder drauf sind. Also
es gibt welche, die behaupten, ernsthaft, der Grand Canyon ist in einer Woche
entstanden. Also das ist so 3-Head, das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Ich gucke so
Verschwörungstheorien Videos mittlerweile richtig gerne, weil das einfach so
lustig ist teilweise.
Ist glaube ich laut genug.
Alter, der Typ hört sich ja so krass Kokona an, mehr Kokona kannst du dich ja gar nicht
anhören.
Ah ja.
Ein Washed Out Dam?
Was?
Der will, der vergleicht ernsthaft einen Haufen Dreck in seinem Garten oder wo auch
immer das ist oder hinter seinem Garten mit dem Grand Canyon. Sehe ich das jetzt
richtig?
Monarch S, Alter. Einfach mal hier der krasseste Miktrop Beweis, kannst du nichts gegen sagen.
Hat er da ernsthaft den Kram ausgedruckt, um das zu zeigen? Also man hätte ja
durchaus einfach im Video Editor irgendwelche Bilder auferlegen können, aber
der hat die alle ausgedruckt und an irgendeine Wand gehängt oder was?
Ich erkenne nix, ist so pixellig.
Natürlich.
Ich meine, was will er uns eigentlich sagen, dass große Wassermassen Dreck wegwaschen
können oder so? Das ist ja schon, also das bestreitet glaube ich auch niemand.
Das Problem ist halt, dass der Grand Canyon im Felsen ist. Und Felsen und Dreck und
Sand ist doch schon ein bisschen was anderes. Ich meine, man sieht es ja schon
daran, man könnte sich ja zum Beispiel mal einen Block Stein nehmen, oder nimmt
man so einen Kircher Hochdruckreiniger und sprüht da mal eine Woche drauf. Was
meint ihr? Ist der Stein danach noch da oder nicht?
Chet, wie schätzt ihr das ein? Oder hat der Stein ein Loch oder nichts nach der
Woche? Stein komplett weg natürlich.
Was gibt das jetzt?
Das ist einfach nur Sand und Dreck. Was ist denn das für ein bescheuerter
Vergleich? Fels, Sand und Dreck.
Und ich meine, das hier mit dem Grand Canyon zu vergleichen ist vielleicht auch
ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Die Musik ist glaube ich von dem. Das sollte sich in irgendeiner Art und Weise
inspirierend anhören oder so.
As we discussed before, people like Kent and Matt Powell don't have the millions
or billions of years to play with when they talk about stuff like this. So,
they of course come up with a story that satisfies all their followers. However,
here in the real world, Kent, your story won't wash. See what I did there?
Wie sie so diese Musik da drunter gelegt haben, so nach dem Motto, er revealed jetzt
das große Secret, was niemand möchte, dass man es weiß.
Alter, der Typ, der ist so krass Kokona, das ist quasi, okay, der ist nicht dick genug,
aber der ist so, der ist komplett von der Sprechweise und allem und dem was
erzählt. Es ist so der Inbegriff von Kokona, also mehr geht eigentlich kaum noch.
Es ist eine Straße aus Sand.
Das ist aber kein Stein.
Und ja, selbst wenn ich weiß, ja, also jetzt kommt er wahrscheinlich als
nächstes damit an, ja, guck mal hier, hier wurde auch mal irgendwie eine Straße
weggeschwemmt oder sowas. Ja, ja, das kann schon sein, wenn eine Straße
weggeschwemmt wird oder irgendwie durchbricht an eine Brücke und was auch
immer. Das mag alles schon vorgekommen sein, aber ich weiß nicht, wie groß ist
der Grand Canyon? Das Ding ist ja hunderte, wenn nicht tausende Kilometer lang
und irgendwie, was weiß ich, wie breit. Das kann sie weder mit einer Brücke noch
mit so einem Dreckhügel vergleichen.
Hat er das jetzt hoch gerechnet oder was?
Okay, also wir wissen jetzt, die Straße hier durchzubrechen für das Wasser hat
eine Stunde gedauert, dementsprechend hat der Grand Canyon auch nur eine Woche
gedauert. Alles klar.
Ich würde mal sagen, aber wobei, ich lasse ihn erst mal ausgehen.
Ich würde mal sagen, er leckt Critical Information oder was denkt ihr? Also es
glaube ich der beste, beste Beispiel dafür, wie man aussieht, wenn man sehr
viele Critical Information leckt.
Er will uns sagen, das Wasser wird dann quasi zur
zum Tunnelbohrer oder was?
Was? Was? Sekunde, Sekunde, was?
Das ist der Beweis oder was?
Das ist der Beweis, okay. Wie heißt das auf der? Die Sinnflut war das, ja genau. Also die Sinnflut ist quasi, hat quasi Seen
aufgefüllt und die sind dann quasi den Berg runter gelaufen und haben den Grand Canyon geformt oder was?
Warum zeigt er uns eigentlich jetzt einen Haufen Dreck?
Das meint, das meint er wirklich ernst.
Es ist der Wahnsinn.
Aber der Grand Canyon ist ja kein Damm. Wie kommt er auf die großartige Idee?
Chat, ihr kennt den anscheinend, ich habe von dem doch nie was gehört. Also von Kent Hovind sagt mir nichts.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass der das ist.
Ich kenne mich in der alternativen Faktenwelt auf YouTube nicht so sehr, nicht so gut aus.
Ach, jetzt kriegen wir Fotos gezeigt, wo irgendwelche Dämme kaputtgegangen sind. Ja, schön und gut.
Außerdem würde ich es vielleicht sagen, also wenn er sagt, dass Dämme quasi fehlen all the time, so oft gehen Dämme jetzt auch nicht kaputt.
Es gibt weltweit viele Dämme, es kommt ab und zu mal vorher, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als geht minütlich ein Damm kaputt.
All the time.
Vor allem diese Musik dabei. Ja super, guck mal. Ja super, hier hast du eine Straße mit bisschen Dreck und Kram unten drunter.
Ja gut, da hat wahrscheinlich, was weiß ich, wie viel Wasser dagegen gedrückt. Das sind, was weiß ich, 10 Meter oder so.
Oh, komm schon jetzt. Du wirst dich ernsthaft mit diesem vergleichen.
All of this would be much more amusing of course, if it wasn't for the fact that Kent is totally serious.
Man beachte hier, also ist alles massiver Fels unten drunter.
Oh Mann.
Okay, ich glaube, der Rest muss, oh nee, da kommt jetzt noch was, da kommt jetzt noch was. Ich dachte, er zeigt uns jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Dammbilder.
Nee, kommt nix mehr.
Vielleicht ist es sein Geschäftsmodell, das kann schon sein, wahrscheinlich kann man damit sogar Geld verdienen.
Ja genau, wie gesagt, nehmen den Kircher Hochdruckreiniger und lass den mal auf den Stein sprühen für eine Weile und dann gucken wir uns den Stein an.
Ich würde noch nicht einfach Wasser drüber lassen, sondern wirklich mal einen Hochdruckreiniger nehmen, also richtig dicken Felsen hinstellen.
Also ich mein, ich hab mit dem Hochdruckreiniger auch schon oft genug Bodenplatten bei mir im Hof gereinigt und naja, also passiert ist da nix.
Aber ich hab's auch keine Woche drauf gelassen.
Okay, ist fertig. Meine Güte, ey, das ist so unglaublich, ich komm da drauf nicht klar. Der ganze Hof hat sich aufgelöst, ja.
Chat jetzt verratet nicht alles, allein schon weil ich jetzt sage, dass mein Hof noch intakt ist, da muss ich ja Teil, wie nennt man das eigentlich, so Teil des schlafenden Mainstreams sein.
Siehst du dich als teilweise selbstständig, da du YouTube und Twitch machst? Na ja gut, ich hab ne eigene Firma, deswegen angemeldet, also das sagt man da angemeldet.
Ja, was auch immer, also ja schon, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich keine Big Stonks Millionen mache oder so damit.
Jetzt hab ich einen Grand Canyon im Hof, genau, nach dem Hochdruckreinigern.
So, das gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes, ich würd sagen wir gucken uns Unexpected Smart Drawbell Home Automation Ideas an.
Das haben wir hier zu bieten. Ja, Fireship ist übrigens ein guter Channel, den weiß ich gar nicht warum ich den noch auf hab, wahrscheinlich wollte ich gucken was es da so gab.
Oh, Chat, wie siehts aus? Java in 100 Sekunden, wollen wir uns das geben heute? Aber nicht gleich, aber nicht gleich.
Okay komm, wir geben es jetzt, Java in 100 Sekunden. Jetzt ist natürlich auch die Frage, Java oder Java?
Oder so richtig schön auf Deutsch, Java, Java, er auch Java.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das das Java Maskottchen ist, dachte die haben immer diesen komischen Kaffeebecher da drauf.
Ich hab mich schon öfters gefragt, was ist dieses hässliche Ding bei manchen Java Projekten, aber das ist das Java Maskottchen, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Könnt ihr euch noch vor ein paar Jahren erinnern, da war das ja das Big Buzzword, da hat jeder gesagt MapReduce, Hadoop, MapReduce, keiner wusste so genau von was er spricht, aber MapReduce.
Aber mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr so, das war jetzt schon 5 Jahre her oder sowas, das war noch zur Anfangszeit von alles mit Cloud ist nice.
Wo es eine Runtime gibt, wohlgemerkt, natürlich muss es eine Runtime geben.
Sieht die Seite heute tatsächlich immer noch so aus wie aus 1990er Zeiten? Nee, oder? Das ist doch mittlerweile schon. Moment.
Download Java.
Ok, die Seite sieht immer noch ein bisschen aus wie 1990. Ja.
Wir hatten keinen Bock das zu aktualisieren.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie 1990.
Vor allem als gäbe es keine Monitore, die breiter sind als 800 x 600 oder sowas in der Richtung.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Das könnte bis jetzt auch noch Valet C Sharp sein, also bis dahin ist es kein Unterschied.
Das würde auch noch funktionieren, das auch noch, das auch noch.
Ne, das nicht mehr. Aber fast.
Klassische Objektorientierungsstelle.
Es war eh so der Trend der letzten paar Jahre, dass viele klassischen objektorientierten Programmiersprachen immer mehr funktionale Sachen bekommen haben. Was ich nice finde, sogar C++.
Wobei man sagen muss, um das wirklich Enterprise Create zu machen, geht das so nicht. Da kannst du nicht einfach irgendwie Hello World printen oder so.
Da brauchst du erstmal eine Printer Class, eine Printer Factory, das ist ganz wichtig, ein Printer Factory Manager.
Und damit nicht jeder eine Printer Factory instanziert, machst du da eine aus ein Printer Factory Manager Singleton, dass das funktioniert.
Du brauchst schon mal mindestens 20 Klassen und mindestens 600 Zeilen Code, dass du hier überhaupt Hallo Mama schreiben kannst auf der Konsole.
Dependency Injection, ja auch ganz wichtig, ganz ganz wichtig. Wie soll man denn, wie soll man überhaupt ordentliches Logging betreiben ohne Dependency Injection?
Was ist eine Factory? Eine Factory ist eine Klasse, mit der du andere, mit der du andere Klassen instanzierst.
Wo du dann quasi schon Default Parameter setzen kannst und so Digger. Oder sie irgendwo anders registrieren bevor du sie zurück gibst.
Das ist nicht Enterprise genug. Nicht Enterprise genug.
Das ist ein Channel den kann ich wirklich empfehlen, ich finde den richtig gut. Also der hat wirklich jeden einzelnen seiner Subscriber hier voll verdient finde ich. Und ich weiß nicht wie er das macht.
Der hat früher zwar auch viele Videos gemacht, aber nicht so mega krass viele. Aktuell haut er alle zwei drei Tage in den Video raus.
Keine Ahnung wie er das treibt, aber die sind immer echt gut die Videos.
Ich hab das Gefühl langsam gehen die Themen aus, der hat ja schon fast alles durch hier. Was ist denn das erste Video von ihm?
Zeig mal. Ups. Oldest. Angular. Ja da war das auch ein bisschen langsamer alles. Aber es ist ein wirklich guter Channel.
Kann ich empfehlen zu abonnieren, wenn man so Überblick haben will. Technikrams und auch irgendwelche neueren JavaScript Entwicklungen. Der macht ja relativ viel Frontend Zeug.
Die ganze Redaktion dahinter. Mittlerweile bestimmt ja.
Ok, jetzt haben sie aber alle ein Video dazu gemacht oder?
Jetzt haben sie alle ein Video dazu gemacht.
Nein ich nicht, aber mach ich auch nicht. Mach ich auch nicht.
Co-Pol in 100 Sekunden. Was zum? Moment was?
Ein fliegender Laubbläser. Moment das muss ich mir jetzt kurz angucken ob das ernsthaft?
Ich will den ganzen Bauprozess nicht sehen. Ich will einfach nur sehen ob es fliegt oder nicht.
Ok, ich will eigentlich nur sehen, wie es fliegt. Ich will den ganzen Bauprozess nicht sehen.
Na gut, der fliegt ja zu gut, weil man den ganzen Bauprozess nicht sehen kann.
Ein Laubbläser.
Die Flügel sind einfach mal durchgebrochen.
Auf den Laubbläserflieger.
Ich meine es macht eigentlich keinen Sinn, aber cool dass es funktioniert.
Ich meine warum einen Laubbläser drauf machen, wenn man einfach einen Akku mit Propeller drauf machen kann.
Warum aus Pappe, da bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher. Ich vermute mal, weil das ein ganz gutes Kompromiss aus Gewicht und Stabilität ist in dem Fall.
Das wiegt ja schon ein bisschen was, das zieht auch ein bisschen was dran.
Funktioniert. Der Laubbläser regelt.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ok, nächstes Video.
Wir skippen mal den Graben dazwischen.
Nicht so die Frühlinge.
Das ist ein uralt Video. Oh, oh, oh, da hebt er ab. Da geht er steil hier.
Die eine Kapriole.
Ich versuche nur nur eine Strecke zu machen.
Alles klar.
Etwa halbwegs da.
Es funktioniert!
Es funktioniert wirklich, aber wir fliegen mit einem Leapflower.
Wie lange kann das Ding denn fliegen?
Wie lange hält denn der Akku von so einem Laubbläser auf voller Pulle?
Bestimmt nicht so lang.
Auf der anderen Seite, der bläst ja nicht warm. Wenn der warm blasen würde, wäre der Akku instant leer.
Aber der bläst ja nur. Ach, könnte wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen gehen.
Die wollen die rechts und links lenken.
Da hätten wir uns jetzt den Bauprozess angucken müssen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, die haben vielleicht was hinter in den Luftfluss vom Laubbläser gebaut, was sie fernsteuern können.
Weil hier irgendwie an den Flügeln und an das Pappe, da haben die wahrscheinlich nichts großartig dran.
Aber zumindest einen Höhenruder bräuchte man ja.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Müsste man sich den Bauprozess angucken. Hab ich jetzt aber keinen Bock zu.
Ich wollte eigentlich bloß sehen, wie der Laubbläser fliegt.
Guck mal, sogar gelandet, ohne dass es kaputt geht.
Ich meine, coole Sache ist es schon.
Es ist zwar unglaublich sinnlos, aber ja doch, guck mal.
Nee, die haben schon irgendwie gebaut, dass man steuern kann.
Ich meine, der Sound hört sich an, als fliegt irgendwie ein Jet vorbei.
Und...
Guck mal, da ist sogar noch eine Kamera draufgebappt.
Stream to Battlefield, wir basteln heute in Portal was, ja.
Ah, jetzt habe ich es erkannt.
Hier, also hier können sie steuern, wie viel das Ding quasi pumpt.
Nee, pumpt ist das falsche Wort, pustet.
Also irgendwas angeschlossen hier an. Wahrscheinlich ist das hier der Hebel, wo man halt normalerweise...
Ja, guckt hier.
Hier drückt das wahrscheinlich einfach rein, wie sehr...
Also schon eine coole Konstruktion.
Eigentlich richtig nice.
Fliegt sich wahrscheinlich besser als die Jets in Battlefield 2042.
Sliderman.
Richtig nice.
Das musst du auch erstmal hinkriegen.
Fuck. Gut, dass uns das YouTube empfohlen hat, sonst wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen nach Flying Leafblower zu suchen.
Die wollen es aber echt wissen, oder?
Was ist Battlefield Portal? Das ist in Battlefield 2042 ein Creation Community, Creation Tool, wo du deine eigenen Spielmodi bauen kannst.
Es hat aber kein Level Editor oder sowas, es ist jetzt kein komplettes Modding Framework.
Du hast aber einen Logik Editor, wo du theoretisch die schon bestehenden Spielmodi customisieren kannst.
Das probieren wir mal aus. Ich habe noch nichts damit gemacht, keine Ahnung.
Und warum genau soll ich das jetzt aufmachen, den Windows Start Sound?
But why?
Was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Unexpected Smart Doorbell Automation.
Okay, da ist was für den Heim Automatisierer in mir jetzt wieder dabei.
Ich habe keine Video Doorbell, aber was ich habe ist, ich habe eine Doorbell und eine Videokamera.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch als Video Doorbell zählt, aber ich habe eine Kamera Feed von der Tür und ich habe eine Gegensprecheranlage, die eingebunden ist.
Ich habe übrigens das falsche E-Mode eingeplant.
Glaubst du, man findet mit 24 noch eine Ausbildung? Klar, warum nicht?
Selbstverständlich findest du mit 24 schon eine Ausbildung.
Natürlich.
Da gibt es überhaupt keine Probleme. Ich würde mal sogar sagen, es gibt bestimmt einige Arbeitgeber, die es sogar zu schätzen wissen mit 24, weil Leute mit 24 sind in der Regel zuverlässiger als Leute mit 16, 17, 18, aber vielleicht etwas gefestigter als Leute mit 16, 17, 18.
Und du findest eigentlich heutzutage mehr oder weniger fast immer eine Ausbildung.
Natürlich irgendwann fällst du schon ein bisschen auf, wenn du mit 40 in der Berufsschule sitzt, falls man überhaupt noch in die Berufsschule muss.
Aber ja, das ist kein Problem. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du hast wahrscheinlich was anderes gelernt und willst jetzt nochmal komplett was anderes machen.
Kann ich verstehen, ich hatte ja einen ähnlichen Werdegang. Ich habe ja auch erstmal Stonks Zeug gelernt.
Das ist, worüber ich nie was erzähle, weil ich damit nichts mehr zu tun haben will.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, nee, das ist nichts für mich, das mache ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich zum Glück die Ausbildungsstelle als Fachinformatiker bekommen beim Provider.
Also wie gesagt, kein Problem.
Nichts mit Holz, nein. Mit Holz hat das Arbeitsamt gesagt, ich soll was mit Holz lernen.
Zum Glück habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich mag keine Kinder. Ich kann machen, was ich will, jedes Mal, wenn ich Kinder höre, habe ich so innerlich das Verlangen, das auszuschalten.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, das braucht ja keiner. Sieh los.
Also allein schon, nee, nee, nee.
Aber nicht mehr mit dieser Automation.
Wenn eine Person auf der Doppelkamera entdeckt wurde,
plus einer von uns ist zu Hause,
und dann öffnet niemand die vorderste Tür nach zwei Minuten,
werden wir bemerkt.
Zuerst auf den Echoes.
Dann bekomme ich eine Notifikation auf meinem Telefon,
die mir eine Bilder von dem, was auf meinem Portemonnaie ist,
weil es wahrscheinlich eine Package ist, die ich nehmen muss.
Auch keiner. Aber ich habe ja mittlerweile, es ist bei mir auch so gemacht, dass ich auf dem Handy quasi angerufen werde, wenn einer an der Tür klingelt. Ich könnte dann mit denen auch theoretisch reden, will ich aber nicht.
Ich finde es aber immer ganz interessant, dass ich weiß, wenn es geklingelt hat und ich nicht da war, das finde ich insofern ganz interessant,
weil manchmal eben DHL oder Hermes, DPD, Amazon Logistics, wobei Amazon Logistics muss ich ausnehmen, Amazon Logistics schmeißt es einfach über einen Zaun im Zweifelsfall und verpisst sich wieder,
sein kann, dass die sagen, sie haben es versucht zuzustellen, es war keiner da, und sie haben es gar nicht versucht zuzustellen.
Oder nichts einwerfen oder so. Also ich finde es ganz gut zu wissen, wenn es geklingelt hat.
Okay, das ist keine schlechte Sache, dass man nochmal erzählt bekommt, so nach dem Motto, okay du bist jetzt heimgekommen, es war jemand da und hat ein Paket abgelegt, das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das scheitert bei mir allerdings schon dadurch, dass ich keinerlei Amazon Echoes oder Voice Assistants habe und ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht das Verlangen verspüre, mir welche hinzustellen.
Aber man könnte natürlich auch einfach eine Smartphone Notification schicken, das muss ja nicht vorlesen.
Geht das eigentlich mit dem Datenschutz klar, zum Beispiel Postboten oder so aufzunehmen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber ich nehme den Postboten ja auch nicht auf, also du kannst kein Gesicht oder so erkennen, aus dem Winkel.
Du kannst eigentlich so gut wie nichts erkennen, außer dass jemand die Klingel gedrückt hat. Und meine Hauswand mit der Klingel darf ich aufnehmen.
Wie macht man das am besten mit der Smartphone Notification, aber das kann ich jetzt nicht so im kurzen sagen.
Also wenn du Android hast, das ist gar kein Problem. Wenn du Android hast, kannst du Notifications schicken, ohne dass du irgendwas brauchst.
Wenn du iOS hast, musst du sowas wie Push Over oder so verwenden. Irgendeine Push Notification App, weil Apple hat ja gesagt,
wir machen bei allen möglichen Sachen wieder unser eigenes Suppechen.
Na super, da guckt er jetzt mal ernsthaft. Ich gehe gerade von meinem 0815 Amazon Logistics Zusteller aus.
Als wird der lesen, was bei mir auf der Klingel am Display steht.
Die können meistens noch nicht mal Deutsch oder Englisch lesen überhaupt. Zumindest bei mir, die Amazon Logistics Zusteller.
Also ich habe da so meine Zweifel, dass das irgendetwas bringen würde.
Okay, das ist so eine typische Kokona-Geschichte hier.
Door ist open und wenn dann einer reinkommt, der nicht reinkommen soll, dann holt man erstmal die Shotgun raus.
Freedom!
Hast du dein Haus gekauft oder mietest du? Weder noch.
Das ist das Haus vom Opa geerbt. Also der Opa hat das ja auch nicht selbst gebaut.
Ich glaube, gebaut hat das Haus sein Opa, also quasi mein Ur-Opa dann oder so.
Und er hat das halt ziemlich ausgebaut. Also das zweite Stockwerk hat er gebaut und die Garage hat er gebaut.
Und wir haben jetzt auch noch einiges umgebaut wieder, aber jetzt haben wir nichts obendrauf gebaut, also ein paar innen drin halt komplett renoviert 2013.
War auch nicht billig, aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall mehr als selbst was zu bauen.
Also ich glaube, mein DHL-Lieferant wird wegrennen, wenn da sowas aus der Klingel kommt.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Ja, sowas ähnliches habe ich beim Telefon klingeln. Telefon klingeln pausiert den Fernseher, wenn er an ist, oben automatisch, also die Wiedergabe.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, das finde ich g'sinnig.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee. Stell dir mal vor, da erschreckst du dich, guckst in den Film, auf einmal blendet es rüber und du siehst DHL mal an deinem Tor.
Das finde ich tatsächlich etwas angenehmer.
Also ich sag dir, ohne Scheiß, wenn das Ding Motion erkennt und in meinem Bett, also in meinem Nachts würde es auf einmal anfangen rot zu flackern, da würde ich mich ja des Todes erschrecken.
WTF?
Wobei, bei den Amis ist es so, der hat wahrscheinlich erstmal die M16 unter dem Bett liegen und holt das Ding dann raus, sobald das Motion Sensor am Start hat.
Aber M16 burst.
Motion vor der Tür, Zeit für Panik.
Echt?
Ernsthaft meint ihr, da fällt irgendjemand drauf rein auf so ein Gebelle?
Das ist exakt der gleiche Ton in einem immer gleichen Rhythmus, so bellt doch kein Hund.
Das ist praktisch, allerdings hätte ich eh das Handy mit und würde es mitbekommen.
Also zwei coole Ideen waren dabei, aber der Rest ist ziemlich sinnlos.
Runde Sound as a Service, genau.
Also zwei, drei Sachen waren ganz sinnig, der Rest ist für mich nicht relevant.
AI Hunde Sound, wir hatten schon AI Fisch Kai, warum sollten wir nicht AI Hunde Sound haben?
Okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Was passiert, wenn man eine Atombombe auf den Mond schießt?
Ja, das interessiert mich, was passiert?
Was passiert dann?
Wahrscheinlich explodiert sie und dem Mond passiert gar nichts.
Also ich predicte jetzt mal was.
Das macht erstens mal kein Knall, weil nichts da ist, um Schallwellen zu übertragen.
Es wird wahrscheinlich ein kleines Loch in den Mond machen und umsonst nichts.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Okay.
Schauen wir uns das mal an, was passiert?
Bäm.
Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass der Mond näher an die Erde rückt dadurch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass dazu eine Atombombe, was auch immer dafür eine dran ist, ausreicht.
Es sind ja auch schon irgendwie Asteroiden und sonstige Sachen auf den Mond eingeschlagen,
das den Mond auch nicht groß bewegt.
Was, wenn wir eine gewaltige Atombombe auf den Mond schießen würden?
Ja, auf erzählen.
Nee, das glaube ich, das kann ich mir echt nicht vorstellen.
Könnte der Mond sogar zu einem tödlichen Meteoriten Hagel zerfallen?
Das glaube ich auch nicht, das ist viel zu wenig.
Da müsste schon was ganz anderes da anrücken.
Moment, warum haben wir das Untertitel?
Das ist auf Deutsch, da brauchen wir kein Untertitel.
Aha.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, je nachdem wo die sind und das einschlägt, ob das für die so gut ausgeht.
Also zünden wir die Bombe und wechseln in die Zeitlupe.
Außerhalb der Bombe passiert ein paar Millisekunden gar nichts.
Im Inneren verursachen hoche explosive Sprengstoffe aber eine Drohquelle, die den radioaktiven Metallkern so stark zusammenpresst,
dass er die kritische Masse überschreitet.
Bombe.
Wobei es im Weltall noch nicht mal Bombe macht.
Ja, finde ich auch gut.
Da willst du auf jeden Fall nicht in der Nähe sein.
Aha.
Monarch-S-Time.
Ah.
Also im Prinzip ist man im Arsch, wenn man da in der Nähe ist.
Das sieht man, ist im Arsch, wenn man da in der Nähe ist.
Auf der anderen Seite des Mondes wüsste man vielleicht nicht, dass es eine Explosion gab.
Das Beben würde sich anfühlen, als hätte ein Asteroid von der Größe der Cheops-Pyramide eingeschlagen.
Ja, und es kommt ja öfters mal vor, dass da was einschlägt und die Umlaufbahn verändert sich nicht.
Und es ist immer noch nicht vorbei.
Wo die Bombe explodiert, spritzt der Boden auf wie Wasser, wenn ein Stein hineinfällt.
Trifft die Explosion auf die Mondoberfläche, kann sie bis zu 100 Millionen Kubikmeter Staub und Fels ausgraben und einen Krater von einem Kilometer Durchmesser schaffen,
während der Grund zu Schutt pulverisiert wird.
Trümmer schießen in alle Richtungen zum Himmel auf.
Ohne Atmosphäre gibt es wie gesagt keinen bremsenden Luftwiderstand.
Der meiste versprengte Schutt fällt nie wieder zum Mond zurück und fliegt so schnell davon, dass er der Gravitation entwischt.
Jetzt düst also ein Schauer aus Mikro-Meteoriten durch Sonnensüße.
Das macht uns ja nichts, das verklüht ja alles.
Viele davon werden auf die Erde prasseln, auch wenn sie kaum größer als ein Kieselstein sind.
Aber für Satelliten, Astronauten oder Raumstationen, die im Weg sind, ist der Spaß vorbei.
Andere Mikro-Meteoriten fliegen in ganz unterschiedlichen Winkeln und Geschwindigkeiten davon und verteilen sich über die gesamte Mondoberfläche.
Wie Geschosse löchern sie unsere neugierigen Astronauten ganz egal wo.
Schließlich endet die Explosion.
Auf der Erde würde jetzt ein Feuerball wie ein Heißluftballon aufsteigen und eine Art Säule bilden.
Beim Aufsteigen zieht er keine Luft an, wodurch der obere Teil zum Atompilz verlornt.
Aber wir wissen ja langsam, auf dem Mond gibt es keine Atmosphäre, also auch keinen Atompilz.
Je weiter sich der Plasmaball ausbreitet, umso stärker kühlt er ab und umso weniger Energie hat er, um Angst unschreckend zu verbreiten.
Schon wenige Sekunden nach der Explosion verfärbt sich die Kugel rot und wird langsam unsichtbar.
Von der Erde aus gesehen wäre die Explosion wie ein Stern, der kurz aufflammt und gleich wieder verblasst.
Ein Funkel, dann nichts mehr.
Die Wolke aus winzig kleinem Schutt steigt hoch über die Mondoberfläche auf und wird für einige Minuten von der Sonne beleuchtet.
Ein schaurig schönes Spektakel, zumindest falls es noch jemanden gibt, um es zu beobachten.
Und die Mondumlaufbahn, die bleibt quasi unverändert.
Den Mond mit einer Atombombe verschieben zu wollen, ist etwa so, als wollte man einen Laster durch Anpusten bewegen.
Atomexplosionen sind groß, aber das All ist größer.
Unsere Explosion hinterlässt nur einen weiteren unter Millionen Kratern.
Auf dem Mond bleibt es aber ungemütlich.
Die Trümmer, die doch zurückfallen, sind radioaktiv.
Und weil keine natürlichen Vorgänge sie wegwaschen oder unter sich begraben, bleibt die Mondoberfläche kontaminiert.
Innerhalb eines Jahres zerfällt die Strahlung aber zum Glück auf ein Niveau, das mit der natürlichen kosmischen Strahlung vergleichbar ist.
Demond wäre es also ziemlich egal, wenn er von einer Atombombe getroffen würde.
Richtig dumm gelaufen, nur für alle, die jemals zum Mond wollen.
Oder dort sogar praktische Infrastruktur aufbauen.
Vielleicht lassen wir das mit der Atombombe auf dem Mond also lieber einfach.
Vielleicht sollen wir das mit Atombomben allgemein lassen, nicht nur auf dem Mond, so überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das wäre doch auch keine schlechte Idee, glaube ich.
Was? Ich stehe kurz davor, eine Wohnung zu kaufen.
Denkst du für mich alleine reicht 50 Quadratmeter?
Ja.
Ja, je nachdem. Kommt halt auf dich an, also mir würde das reichen.
Mir würde das reichen.
Man braucht ein Zimmer, ein ordentliches Arbeitszimmer für Homeoffice, PC und alles.
Ein Schlafzimmer, fertig, reicht doch.
Bad Küche zählt ja nicht dabei.
Küche muss ja auch nicht groß sein.
Das reicht, dicke.
Aber letztendlich kann ich das ja natürlich bei dir nicht wissen, wie anspruchsvoll du da bist oder was du alles machen willst.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein eigenes Gewächshaus brauchst oder so, Vape Nation, keine Ahnung, dann reicht es nicht.
Kann man ja pauschal schlecht sagen, also mir würde das reichen.
Also mir würde das, mir würde das wahrscheinlich reichen.
Aber ich bin da eh nicht so anspruchsvoll, also.
Ja, sehe ich auch so aus.
Ordentliches Büro arbeiten und halt für Arbeitszimmer, PC, Spielzimmer in einem quasi.
Und den Rest bräuchte ich nicht. Schlafzimmer, ja.
Also mir würde das reichen.
Guck mal, ob ich mein eigenes erst mal ein eigenes Video auf hab.
Das hat 600 Comments jetzt.
So YouTube gibt gibt es doch noch irgendwas. Wir sind wir sind da durch.
Es gab heute nicht viele Videos, die empfohlen wurden, war eigentlich nur Schwachsinn dabei.
Du bist bei dem Video eingeschlafen. Ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Ich hab dich quasi in den Schlaf geschwätzt.
Bei Video.
USB so ein Scheiß, ne Alexi Bexy kann ich mir nicht geben.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Man, das singst Koalas ACGI gibt immer noch genug Verrückte.
Was machen die Österreicher?
Wir machen nachher wahrscheinlich gleich Portal.
Wir versuchen, bis in den Portal rumzubauen, weil oft das normale Battlefield 2042 habe ich.
Ich habe gestern ganzen Tag gespielt, nicht so wahnsinnig viel Bock heute noch.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, weiß zwar nicht, was da abgeht, aber.
Das ist richtig gut gemacht.
Das war kurz, aber das sah nach Arbeit aus.
Muss er immer ein einzelnes Foto machen, dann um, dann weiterstellen, noch ein Foto machen.
Was ist das Video, wo er sein Dislikebot zeigt?
Jetzt nicht noch Promoten, oder?
Jetzt haben wir uns ein Video angeguckt und gleich geht es weiter mit irgendwelchen Videos in der Richtung.
Die Definitive Edition ist Rockstars größte Plamage.
Ich bin zwar kein GTA Fan, aber.
Was?
Echt?
Moment, Moment.
Nur mal, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Die haben doch erst die ganze Welt verklagt und gesagt, irgendwie Remakes nehmt eure Sachen runter.
Mods Seiten löscht eure Mods und jetzt wird das wieder gelöscht.
Ich habe gar nicht mitbekommen, dass es überhaupt raus ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Man muss mal sagen, ich finde, es passt irgendwie.
Sekunde.
Selbst wer das Spiel gekauft hat.
Irgendwie passt das grafisch, finde ich kaum noch richtig.
Die Charaktere, also das hier sieht viel zu realistisch aus für die Charaktere, oder?
Wobei, der Rest sieht auch ein bisschen eckig.
Kann es aktuell nicht spielen, allerdings sind nicht die ganzen technischen und ästhetischen Probleme,
die kurz nach dem Release für Sport und Kritik sorgten der Grund für diesen radikalen Schritt.
Aber da其實 mehr über die animale Welt zu wissen, waren wohl noch Daten in der veröffentlichten Version drin,
die nicht hätten drin sein sollen, schimpfische Kommentare der Entwickler und Quellcode.
Okay, Triggert, Triggert, muss jetzt mal kurz, kurz, kurz lesen, wo das Problem ist.
This shit dosent work the way around and below, so we'll just show the text and place.
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich mein, warum soll man im Southcourt noch eben ein bisschen rumflamen?
Oho!
Toss!
In jedem Fall kein guter Start für die Rückkehr von drei der wichtigsten Werke der Spielegeschichte. Dass die Neuauflagen von GTA 3, Vice City und San Andreas für Diskussionen sorgen würden, war abzusehen. Schon nach dem ersten, nicht mal eine Minute langen Trailer...
Was ist am zweiten Kommentar so schlimm?
Keycard to the cells can be found upstairs in the station...
Wo ist das Problem?
... dass die alten Spiele nicht in der Optik von GTA 5 zurückkommen würden und dann wiederum waren noch einige konkrete Änderungen der Neuauflagen sofort ein Streitpunkt, beispielsweise der Plastik-Look der Charaktere.
Andererseits zeigte schon der erste Trailer, dass die Definitive Edition von der technischen Seite aus gesehen ein super spannendes Projekt werden würde. Teilweise bieten die neuen Versionen Grafikeffekte, die es nicht mal bei GTA 5 gibt, beispielsweise von Explosionen ausgelöste Schatten.
Und auch die 3D-Räume hinter den Fenster-Texturen, die ich vor einigen Tagen in meinem Analyse-Video zu den ersten Screenshots nur vermuten konnte, haben sich nun als wahr herausgestellt und können fast überall in den komplett neu gebauten Spielwelten gefunden werden.
Außerdem gibt es jetzt in GTA 3 erstmals eine Ingame-Map und man kann Missionen direkt neu starten, muss also nicht immer erst zum Missionsgeber zurückfahren.
Solchen offensichtlichen Verbesserungen zusammen mit deutlich besseren Texturen, neuen 3D-Modellen und höherer Sichtweite stehen aber auch viele Änderungen gegenüber, die sich die Spieler seit der Veröffentlichung lustig machen.
Beispielsweise eine Hand von Charaktere, die einfach falsch aussehen. Sogar der Kopf von CJ, immerhin die Hauptfigur von San Andreas, wirkt als sei er viel zu klein im Vergleich mit seinem Körper. Und so kommen Performance-Probleme.
Wahrscheinlich mit der Objektverwaltung des Spiels zu tun haben, denn wenn man sich schnell durch die Welten bewegt, fällt die Frame-Rate regelmäßig unter 60 FPS, selbst auf einem PC mit GeForce 3080.
Es scheint gerade der Monat der schlecht optimierten Spiele zu sein, oder? Da kannst du von 45 FPS Battlefield 2042 zu 50 FPS GTA Remaster wechseln.
Auch wenn die Neuauflage mit exzessiven Scheinwerferschatten und mehr Verkehr und Passanten durchaus viel zu berechnen hat.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von Wild Rift.
Alter! Jetzt aber!
Sellout! Sellout!
Worauf wartest du noch? Ja, ich warte darauf, dass es fertig ist.
Wenn 40 Songs aus den Original-Soundtracks der Spiele gestrichen werden mussten, ist hingegen ein echter Verlust.
Und auch dass die deutschen Versionen der drei Spiele weiterhin geschnitten sind, ist für mich unverständlich.
Bei GTA 3 und Vice City fehlt jegliches Blut und auch andere Inhalte.
Über die Amok-Mission... Die waren ja eh im Original heftig umstritten. Da sind sie alle Amok gelaufen, haben sie gedacht, die Leute fangen jetzt an durchzudrehen, weil sie GTA gespielt haben.
Natürlich streiten, aber dass nicht mal das Blut, das ja in San Andreas dabei ist, für die beiden Vorgänger freigeschaltet wurde, wirkt schon sehr nachlässig.
Was hältst du von Fiverr? Nee, von was? Nee, das sagt mir nix. Fiverr ist Pog.
Klar, die Titel hätten noch mal von der USK geprüft werden müssen, aber Punkt 1, dass die Spiele nicht richtig sind, sind alt genug für eine erneute Prüfung.
Und außerdem, die sind heute viel einsichtiger als früher.
Achso, GTA Multiplayer, kann ich nix zu sagen, spiele ich nicht. Und Punkt 2, ihr wollt mir doch wohl nicht sagen, dass sich Rockstar das nicht leisten kann, wenn es darum geht, die definitiven Versionen von drei ihrer wichtigsten Spiele zu erstellen.
Aber darum ging es ja wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht, sonst wäre das Unternehmen ja vor der Veröffentlichung ehrlicher mit den Kunden gewesen, die sie zu Vorbestellungen verlocken wollten.
Hätte beispielsweise bei der Liste der Verbesserungen nicht den Eindruck erweckt, als würde die Steuerung auf GTA 5 Niveau gehoben werden, wenn in Wirklichkeit nur das Gamepad Layout an das aktuellste Spiel der Reihe angepasst wurde, nicht aber dessen Funktionen übernommen wurden.
Es gibt kein Deckungssystem wie in GTA 5, man kann sich nicht mal ducken. Ein Feature übrigens, das die Originalspiele dank Mods ja durchaus noch bekommen hatten, aber Rockstar hatte in den letzten Monaten...
Die haben so viele Mod-Ersteller und sonstige Sachen verklagt, allein schon deswegen lohnt sich das nicht, also würde ich die nicht unterstützen.
... sich geschlagen, um Mods für die alten Spiele aus dem Verkehr zu ziehen. Und dann wurden auch noch einige Tage vor der Veröffentlichung der Definitive Edition die drei Originalspiele aus dem Verkauf genommen.
Ja, und es wurden sogar Seiten angeschrieben, dass Safe Games sollen gelöscht werden. Safe Games! Die haben wirklich von Anwältenseiten anschreiben, dass das Safe Games gelöscht werden. WTF?
... nur, damit auch wirklich alle brav diese 60 Euro teure Neuauflage kaufen, die sich jetzt allerdings als ziemlich durchwachsenes Stückwerk herausgestellt hat.
Eine Neuauflage, die an vielen Stellen zwar deutliche technische Verbesserungen liefert...
Aber so rockelt!
... aber eher wie eine wild zusammengewürfelte Mod-Zone...
Alter, wenn das jetzt hier im Video schon so rockelt...
Wie schon gesagt, so wirklich überraschend ist das alles gar nicht mal vom Ausmaß des Debakels abgesehen. Rockstar ist berühmt dafür, als Firma eher wenig Einblick in die Entwicklung ihrer Spiele zu bieten.
Und auch die schwammigen Werbeaussagen vor dem Release passen da ganz gut ins Konzept. Auch, dass es bis zur Veröffentlichung keine Testversion gab, hat uns nicht sonderlich überrascht.
Ja, das ist doch immer verdächtig!
Da gehört es wohl dazu, dass man möglichst wenig über seine Spiele preisgibt und Kritiker auch mal auf eine schwarze Liste setzt, ist uns auch schon passiert.
Dafür gibt es dann aber auch Meisterwerke wie Red Dead Redemption oder halt GTA, die dieses Verhalten durch ihren unglaublichen Erfolg ermöglichen.
Soll heißen, ein guter Rockstar kann gerne exzentrisch sein, solange die Show Rockstar...
Was die gegen Modde haben? Wahrscheinlich, dass das Spiel damit besser ist als ihr eigenes und die Leute es nicht kaufen.
So gar nicht. Wobei natürlich auch gesagt sei, dass die drei Definitive Editions gar nicht von Rockstar selbst kommen, sondern von einem kleinen Studio namens Grove Street Games,
die auch schon die Mobile-Umsetzungen einiger GTA-Spiele verantwortet haben und da jeweils auch sehr viel Kritik einstecken mussten.
Ich will den Schwarzen Peter aber nicht den Entwicklern von Grove Street Games in die Schuhe schieben.
Es wäre Rockstars Job gewesen, ein besseres Auge auf die Arbeit des externen Studios zu haben und gegebenenfalls...
Ganz klar, es kann ja auch durchaus möglich sein, dass die gesagt haben, Leute, der Scheiß ist nicht fertig, das ist so Mist und Rockstar hat gesagt, ja, ja, doch, nö, mach halt mal.
Das ist alles in Management-Geschichte. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, als hätte Rockstar kein Geld.
...Versionen von drei der wichtigsten Werke der Spielegeschichte. Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Shit, here we go again.
Und im Kern sind auch die Neuauflagen von GTA 3, Vice City und San Andreas noch gute Spiele. Schließlich sind die Originale eine fast unkaputtbare Vorlage.
Aber Rockstar hätte diese Definitive Edition auch einfach GTA Reforged nennen können, denn so durchwachsen, wie das Ergebnis jetzt geworden ist...
Deforged.
...erinnert die Sammlung eher an das Debakel, das Blizzard da vor rund zwei Jahren mit Warcraft 3 Reforged abgeliefert hat.
Gibt es eigentlich, Leute, falls irgendjemand noch ein bisschen in Auge auf Warcraft 3 Reforged hat, gibt es mittlerweile eigentlich so eine normale Leather im offiziellen Battle.net?
Ich weiß, dass die alle jetzt die externe Seite benutzen, aber gibt es eigentlich so eine normale Leather mittlerweile?
...von der Liebe, die diese Klassiker verdient hätten und die man bei richtig guten Remakes wie der Neuauflage von Mafia 1 oder Demon's Souls spüren kann, die aber auch durchaus in das ein oder andere Remaster der letzten Jahre geflossen ist,
beispielsweise bei Call of Duty, Modern Warfare 1 und Command & Conquer 1, ist hier nicht viel zu spüren.
Stattdessen verpasst der aggressive Kampf gegen Modder und das Löschen der Original Spiele dieser Veröffentlichung...
Das ist lächerlich. Allein schon deswegen sollte man das nicht kaufen.
Ich hoffe wirklich, dass Rockstar dem Entwicklerteam noch die nötigen Ressourcen zur Verfügung stellt, um in kommenden Patches einige der größten Probleme zu beheben, von den Performanceeindrücken bis zu den teils lächerlichen Charaktermodellen.
Denn wenn das nun tatsächlich die Version von GTA 3, Vice City und San Andreas sein sollen, die als einzige kaufbar bleiben...
Und die damit auch maßgeblich den bleibenden Eindruck dieser Klassiker...
Das ist aber auch ein Trend, der mir wirklich auf den Sack geht. Das haben sie ja gemacht, mit Warcraft 3 haben sie es ja auch geschafft,
dass man das Originalspiel dann quasi versucht zu verbannen, damit die Leute das Neue holen müssen. Hat man bei Diablo 2 zum Glück nicht gemacht.
Dann sollten sie vielleicht auch wirklich irgendwann mal zu diesen definitiven Versionen dieser Spiele werden, die der Titel GTA The Trilogy The Definitive Edition bislang leider nur verspricht.
Aber trotz spannender Neuerungen und interessanter technischer Details leider...
GTA 5 ist jetzt ja auch über drei Konsolengenerationen erschienen.
Wann gibt's denn eigentlich GTA 6? Wahrscheinlich nie, oder? Die sind ja immer noch am Melken mit GTA 5 Multiplayer und nochmal Release für die neue Konsolengeneration.
2030, ja frühestens wahrscheinlich.
Kommt dann, wenn Elder Scrolls 6... Nee, äh... Nee, welche Elder Scrolls teilt zwar Skyrim?
Doch Elder Scrolls 6 kommt jetzt, oder? Also jetzt, als nächstes, wenn's denn kommt, also nie.
Also 6, ja.
Also, YouTube möchte unbedingt, dass wir dieses Video gucken, aber da hab ich jetzt eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist der Trick, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist und nicht sagen kann, ignorieren muss man das Video anklicken und direkt zurückswischen, dann weiß YouTube, man möchte es nicht gucken.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Moment, war das nicht der Typ, den wir das letzte Mal geguckt haben, der in jedem zweiten Satz Alexa gesagt hat?
Okay, nein, das ist Schrott-Video. Wobei, wobei.
Wir gehen einfach mal hier unten durch, was es gibt. Also, äh, irgendwie eine komische Kamera, okay, next.
Ein, äh, wahrscheinlich, äh, Haustier-Fütterungs-Ding. Neue Lampe, braucht kein Mensch. Schiena-Resale.
Ami-Kakona-Switch. Allein schon das Formfaktor. Nee, gucken wir uns nicht an, das ist langweilig.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen, ich hab Hunger. Ich weiß, ich bin ein bisschen kürzer on gewesen heute. Wobei, nee, gar nicht, 2,40 passt eigentlich.
Also, wahrscheinlich gucken wir uns heute Mittag Battlefield 2042 Portal an. Ich versuch mal ein bisschen im Logik-Editor rumzubasteln.
Aber ich geh jetzt mal was essen, Leute, ich hab übelst Hunger. Wir sehen uns, ne? Macht's gut, bis denn, see you.
Vielleicht haust du dich noch. Brauchst du noch jemand? Zeig mal her, schnell. Nö, keiner da. Alles klar, bis denn, see you.